Ah, jetzt...
... es lebt.
Captain Seekai, du bist aber schnell!
Du bist aber schnell!
Reiner.
Passive.
Du bist aber schnell!
Deine Finger sind stark genug...
... um verschiedene Geräte zu kontrollieren.
Aber sie haben auch Limitationen.
Speziell, wenn du sie nicht anstecken kannst.
Deine Finger sind stark genug...
... um verschiedene Geräte zu kontrollieren.
Aber sie haben auch Limitationen.
Speziell, wenn du sie nicht anstecken kannst.
Du hattest eine Remote-Finger.
Die Fingerbot ist das kleinste Roboter der Welt...
... um alle Varianten zu kontrollieren.
reaches remotely and smartly.
No expensive replacements required.
All your existing appliances can become...
... smart devices in seconds.
Das robot ist super easy...
mit dem unterscheid das ist genial mit dem unterscheid dass es das schon längst gibt ich habe mir sowas vor ich habe sogar ich habe sogar auf twitter gepostet
ich habe mir genau sowas gekauft vor drei monaten warte mal ich poste es euch was ich mir gekauft habe das ist überhaupt nichts neues das ist das ist ein super teil das ist ein super teil aber ich habe mir genau sowas gekauft warum muss man ein kickstart dafür machen
warte mal warte mal your prime account your orders bot fuck nach was kann ich untersuchen ist das open source wahrscheinlich nicht finger nach was kann ich untersuchen bei amazon robotter switch switch kann ich suchen switch hier das habe ich mir vor das habe ich mir am zweiten oktober bestellt switchbot
hier schaut mal das ist genau das gleiche das habe ich mir bei amazon vor drei monaten bestellt guckt mal ist fast genau das gleiche
guckt mal das ist genau das gleiche guckt mal genau das gleiche wieviel druck kann das aufwüben ich habe es jetzt nicht aus also ich habe es jetzt nicht irgendwo draufdrücken lassen aber also du kannst damit beispielsweise nicht am herd den knopf rein drücken lassen
also also wenn man wenn man nicht am herd am backofen du kannst damit nicht den knopf vom backofen rein drücken lassen weil das ist so ein druckding so ein kriegst du drauf und dann kommt da raus gehüpft das ist doch genau das gleiche ok so jetzt vergleichen wir das mal also ich habe es jetzt gesehen achso und übrigens was es noch was es noch cooles gibt wer jetzt denkt der dieser switchbot den ich mir gekauft habe der kann nur übrigens das scheint krass zu sein
das scheint gerade recht teuer zu sein ich habe das irgendwie noch für 29 euro oder 19 oder was habe ich bezahlt ich sage es euch klar was habe ich dafür bezahlt ich habe zwei stück bestellt 25 euro ist eigentlich auch relativ teuer für so ein kleines futzding aber gut was aber ganz cool ist der hat noch so ein kit dabei so ein kit das man quasi nicht nur schalter drücken kann sondern auch schalter die quasi nach außen gezogen werden müssen nach außen zieht
das ist dann so ein kleines hier kann man in diese in diese öffnung kann man das attachen und dann auf die andere seite dran kleben aber das sieht mir nach einem ziemlichen ripoff aus der switchbot der fingerbot vom switchbot sogar die app sieht ganz schön ähnlich aus übrigens das schöne am switchbot ist man kann es mit der app steuern man muss es aber nicht mit der app steuern man kann es auch ordentlich steuern aber gucken wir uns mal an was die noch so was die sonst noch haben ich mein vergleich mal die dinger kein großer unterschied bis jetzt
aber ist eine geniale idee also das ding ist wirklich ultra praktisch aber es ist halt keine neue idee der fingerbot der naber macht mich fertig
bei dem lichtschalter dafür gibt es die diese diese schnur die man attachen kann also sprich der zieht dann anstatt nur zu drücken
nein ist überhaupt nicht gestellt es ist nicht gestellt das ist überhaupt nicht nein kann nicht sein dass so wie das geschnitten ist ist das bestimmt exakt in dieser zeitlichen abfolge passiert
so easy das hat hat steve jobs auch immer auf seinen alten iphone präsentation gesagt erstmal erstmal schön in der unterwäsche
hat geht nicht weil ihr wisst ihr wisst warum es nicht geht oder man kann niemals sein eine fingerbot cloud
das ist ein schönes thema die namen auf twitch teilweise sind so next level big brain shit dass ich gar nicht weiß ich glaube es soll lainer heißen
das kann ich dir erklären weil ein lichtschalter besser ist als eine smarte lampe denn du möchtest ja auch dieses ding bedienen können per lichtschalter
und wenn du das per lichtschalter also wenn du eine smarte lampe hast und du machst den lichtschalter aus dann ist die smarte lampe aus und du kannst die smarte lampe egal wie smart sie ist nicht einschalten weil sie hat ja keinen strom
das heißt entweder wirst du nie im leben wieder deinen lichtschalter verwenden können oder die app für das smart lightbulb ding nicht das heißt die eigentlich beste variante ist wenn man rgb beleuchtung haben will ist sich eine rgb lampe oder sonst was zu kaufen
okay und aber die steuerung ob licht an oder aus nicht in mit der lampe zu machen oder dem lichtschalter sondern einfach ein relay einzubauen in stelle des lichtschalters dass das licht dass der lichtschalter eben nicht direkt die lampe schalten sondern nicht an den relay schalten das relay schaltet die lampe
das ist high iq dafür gibt es auch schon das richtig passende ding habe ich schon ein paar mal hier im stream gezeigt ich sollte ich sollte von celly ich sollte von ich sollte von celly geld für geld nehmen die dinger sind nämlich richtig gut habe ich bei mir auch schon ein paar am start und zwar products ein celly eins die sind nämlich so klein die sind kleiner als ein sonoff die sind kleiner als ein sonoff die kannst du unter putz in den lichtschalter
einbauen das schließt du dann an sodass der lichtschalter also das da ist ein relay drinne du schließt quasi die lichtschalter hier an die an den dann die switch an du schließt hier den strom an und also sodass es nicht durchgeht und wenn du lichtschalter drückst dann schaltet das relay die lampe das ist das ist sehr praktisch das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen also viel besser als sich irgendwie so ein smart smart licht zu kaufen wofür die lichter gut sind ist halt
wenn man wenn man rgb haben will wobei ich da ganz ehrlich sagen muss ich habe noch keine richtig gute rgb lampe für so eine e was ist das e17 was auch immer fassungen gefunden was ich viel besser finde ist wenn man wirklich schönes schönes belichtungs konzept oder so umsetzen will dann würde ich tatsächlich zu led streifen greifen mit einem microcontroller dran
ja aber ja kann man kann man machen aber ich würde auf jeden fall das schalten über sowas empfehlen oder alternativ wenn man das nicht kann einen switchbot oder eben hier einen fingerbot das ist nicht schlecht das ist das ist nicht übel also ist im prinzip ja ist ja im prinzip ist es ja von der technik her nicht viel unterschied hier schaltet ein schalter den relay der schaltet hier schaltest du quasi einen schalter der deinen schalter schaltet
und den relay ist ja auch nur ein schalter schalter ach du scheiße was denn was denn satz ja und man darf sich übrigens nicht verwirren lassen muss ich hier auch noch mal sagen weil es ist die unglücklichste adresse die adresse ist wirklich absolut low low iq weil die adresse ist
schelle.cloud und wisst ihr was das haupt das haupt verkaufsargument für dieses ding hier ist dass es ohne cloud funktioniert da hat sich da war einer wirklich sehr big brain time am start bei schelle weißte ich baue was wo wo das verkaufsargument schlechthin ist wir benötigen keine cloud und unsere offizielle firm war kann mqtt
kann rest api schlicht kann alles kann alle kann alle offenen protokolle also sprich ich verkaufe das hauptsächlich an leute die keine cloud verwenden wollen du kannst sogar auf github kannst du gucken und dann mache ich eine domain schelle.cloud das genaue gegenteil von dem was ich eigentlich vertreibe
sonoff sonoff das hat beides eine daseinsberechtigung die sonoff dinger sind günstiger und für für geräte die die also für eine lampe oder so ja das sind die sonoffs besser die dinger sind oder was heißt besser ja doch schon besser geeignet weil die sonoffs sind zu die sonoffs sonoff die sonoffs sind halt zu
aber die dinger die sind halt zu da machst du hier hinter schneidest du das kabel von deiner lampe durch und schließt es hier an und kannst dann damit remote schalten unterschiedliche anwendungszwecke unterschiedliche anwendungszwecke das celly ist halt klein das kannst du in die dose in die wand machen das sonoff ist relativ relativ groß also das ist doppelt so groß wie ein celly ungefähr so hintereinander so ein celly hintereinander ist ungefähr so ein sonoff größe
so und da kannst du halt außen rum liegen lassen den celly würde ich nicht außen liegen lassen
orte ne brauchst du nicht und zwar du kannst dass das geht ich zeigst dir was du was du brauchst dafür noch ich immer mal ich guck mal ich guck mal in mein amazon ich gucke in mein amazon sorry leute in mein amazon
amazon wir sind ja wir sind cool wir benutzen den amazon amazon alter ich hab übelst
bin ich am niesen ich bin am husten
du brauchst für den switchboard ist aber dabei musst du nicht extra kaufen
moment du brauchst
eben funktioniert der zweite link nicht da ist so ein kabel dabei das damit kannst du lichtschalter an und ausschalten
da gibt es da gibt es ja gucken wir uns mal gucken wir uns mal das video an wir haben uns sogar schon mal im stream angeguckt ich hab sogar schon mal gezeigt ja zeigt zeigt mal hier sind die teile
hier da da das gezeigt hier da gibt es noch so ein so ein ding das ist so ein so ein wie nennt man das keine glasfaser sieht ein bisschen so aus wie eine glasfaser das machst du da dran und dann ist es quasi invertet also sprich dann kannst du das ding
dann ist es beim einfahren schaltet es ein quasi damit kannst du auch ein lichtschalter schalten funktioniert habe ich ausprobiert
ok schauen wir uns mal an was der fingerbot noch weiteres zu bieten hat ob das einfach nur so ein ripoff ist oder ob das noch irgendwie was was ok erst mal too hot
ja gut das haben die auch das hat der switchbot hat genau das gleiche er hat auch er hat auch so einen hub für leute die zu nup style sind oder selbst einzurechten
das ist genau das gleiche
das ist genau das gleiche nur dass sie da irgendwie so ein saugnapf dran gemacht haben
das ist der ultra krasse ripoff
hab das gesehen genau so genau so funktioniert das mit dem switchbot auch also quasi genau das kann der switchbot auch nur dass der switchbot finde ich deutlich stabiler montiert ist als dieser komische saugnapf hier
ich glaube nicht dass das saugnapf lange hält
nice acting
geil kann ich mit meinem 3d drucker neue fingerbot ärmer ausdrucken
die sollten man 3d drucker erfinden der so schnell druckt wie das hier guckt euch mal wäre das nicht geil hier pass mal auf fertig so ein 3d drucker bräuchte ich
der name ich komme ich komme nicht über den namen hinweg dass das ding wirklich fingerbot heißt
ok das ist tatsächlich der richtige switchbot ripoff
ok switchbot fingerbot da haben sich auch bestimmt schon leute drüber aufgeregt
guck mal das ist ein jahr älter
wisst ihr was das lustige daran ist dass die leute hier gebacked haben so nachdem so was revolutionäres neues und die können sich das gleiche produkt einfach schon kaufen
ich habe dafür nicht eine anzeige bekommen kommt drauf an welches land wie das ausgelegt ob da überhaupt was patentiert ist man muss ja auch mal sagen
ich weiß gar nicht ob das die ob man sich das so wirklich wenn das ist das ist ein roboter finger roboter knopfdrücker das weiß ich ob das so big brain ist dass das weiß ich
aber ich meine die chinesen können pornhub hoodies verkaufen ohne dass es jemand interessiert warum sollen
die nicht auch nur fingerbot machen können kannst du bitte noch mal erklären was das jelly kann habe auch mal geschaut
ob es was gibt was man per schalter selbst und per app steuern könnte wenn der schalter selbst nicht betätigt ist ist das sowas ja das ist ein relay
du schaltest das relay kannst du schalten entweder über wlan mit einer app mit einem mqtt server mit einer heim automatisierung mit was auch immer
oder aber du kannst das relay auch mit dem mit dem mit dem lichtschalter schalten das funktioniert kannst beim jelly kannst du du schließt hier den lichtschalter an
oh fuck ich hab sorry ich weiß aus dem kopf nehmen wir genau wie man es anschließt aber hier kommt der lichtschalter dran ich glaube
hier genau so in der richtung ja doch doch so ein bisschen doof aber das ist genau sowas was du haben willst
du kannst es dann remote schalten oder hier hier jetzt hier ist doch hier ist doch kein hier ist ein schönes bild dazu ja du schließt den lichtschalter an
und du kannst quasi mit dem lichtschalter schaltest du hier drinnen das relay für das licht also sprich du schaltest nicht mit dem lichtschalter das licht
sondern du schaltest mit dem lichtschalter triggerst du das ding und das ding schaltet ein relay für das für das licht um das licht einzuschalten das heißt du kannst das relay auch über wlan triggern
das ding hat das ding hat ein esp 32 drinnen mit wlan kannst du triggern über mqtt über rest über http oder auch über die app von denen geht beides ja und dann kannst du mit dem schalter nach wie vor
licht an und ausschalten das ist für die frau freundin mutter opa oma ganz gut weil die wollen knopfen drücken knopf drücken am eingang da muss licht angehen und es ist halt auch relativ schnell
alle anderen lösungen sind sind nicht so schön es gibt ja quasi auch wlan schalter ja also wlan schalter gibt es ja im prinzip auch die kannst du hin machen aber das dauert
da muss das schalter erst mal zur heimautomatisierung die heimautomatisierung muss das licht schalten und so das ist nicht so
denn son of mini bin ich mir nicht sicher ob der so gut in die dose passt der son of mini kam glaube ich auch später nach dem chalet
son of mini sieht ein ticken größer aus das schöne ist halt die form es ist eng es ist relativ eng in der in der in der dose
aber es passt rein guckt euch mal an jetzt guck ihr zeigt das dass die dose muss das rein also es ist es ist eng aber es geht
und leute macht vorher die sicherung raus ich sag es jetzt nur sollte eigentlich selbstverständlich sein dass man da nicht irgendwie an live kabeln und so rum bastelt aber macht die sicherung raus ich sag es nicht dass
irgendeiner nachher ankommt so nach dem motto max ich bin im krankenhaus weil ich wollte mal ein jelly einbauen ja macht die sicherung aus mal gucken ob man es am ende sieht übrigens ihr könnt das auch euren elektriker machen lassen ist auch kein problem
ich hab das ich hab das auch mit meinem elektriker gemacht weil ich trau ich trau mich an alles mögliche ran zu frickeln bloß bei allem ab 100 volt plus habe ich so ein bisschen schiss das muss nicht unbedingt sein aber jetzt weiß ich wie es funktioniert und das ist ziemlich easy
strom monka es ja ich guck mal was am ende zeigt ihr könnt es auch euren elektriker machen lassen wenn ihr dem sagt ihr wollt irgendwie keine ahnung 10 steckdosen umrüsten da kostet 100 euro
so ich hoffe mal er zeigt am ende weil das ist ganz schön moment hat er sich davor gedrückt zeigt noch mal wie es drin ist weil das ist ganz schön eng
und jetzt den jelly rein zeigt mal wie es fertig aussieht es ist nämlich da ist nicht viel platz drin je nachdem wie viel kabel man drin hat und klemmen ja genau also ihr seht da ist nicht viel platz
und passt und dann zumachen gut ist funktioniert wunderbar das ding das ist wirklich wirklich toll und es ist auch nicht teuer die haben manchmal guck mal 9 euro 90 das ist das ist der preis ist fast schon fast schon in region von einem normalen sunhoff 9 euro 90
kann sie nicht beschweren es kommt aus bulgarien kommt aus bulgarien und der versandt ist auch nicht so teuer die haben noch jede menge mehr die haben beispielsweise auch noch mit power measurement also sprich da kann man dann auch gucken was die angeschlossenen geräte für den strom verbrauchen
so kaufen wir mal den jelly eins und gucken wir was es kosten würde nach deutschland 480 480 also das ist preisleistungsmäßig wirklich in ordnung also wenn ihr euch jetzt irgendwie keine ahnung ich hab ich hab mal irgendwann so ein 20er pack jelly bestellt
ich hab die seite gebackt klipp heute ich hab die seite kaputt gemacht ich refresh mal 20er pack jelly sack wir sind im arsch die seite
so dann legst du noch 17 euro versandt drauf jetzt mal gucken ab wann das ab wann das hoch geht
du kannst das ganze haus mit ausrüsten ich hab übrigens die meisten liegen noch neben mir hier in der kiste das ist wirklich super super preis und ich kann ich kann insofern auch nur empfehlen den hersteller zu unterstützen weil das ist einer der wenigen die von anfang an die ganze sache offen gemacht haben also sprich du kannst dir glaub den sourcecode angucken auf github und die firmwirt die standardmäßig drauf ist du kannst das motor flaschen aber du musst das motor nicht flaschen du kannst die offizielle firmwirt drauf lassen weil die
offizielle firmwirt auch alle schnittstellen beherrscht die man braucht und es gibt sogar noch eine app irgendwo hab ich noch nie ausprobiert wenn man wenn man das nicht in seiner eigenen heim automatisierungslösung integrieren wollte wenn man die einfach einbauen will app verwenden will und gut das ding ist wirklich gut das kann ich kann ich empfehlen also 200 euro mit einem elektriker ja das ist das ist billig das ist richtig billig größte mal woanders deiner das bezahlst du dich ja dumm und dämlich
so viel bezahlte für drei smart klübchen kann man mit ssh drauf zugreifen kann man nicht das sind erst 32 ich habe keine ahnung für den sp 32 ssh sauber gibt vor allem wird es dafür keine schell geben und was soll die scheltern machen
du hast ein web interface du hast ein web interface du hast ein web interface und du hast alle möglichen api schnittstellen die du so brauchst ja leidel macht das das ist das ist wirklich preisleistungsmäßig ist das ding wirklich top und von den funktionen her ist es auch top und kann sich ja mal ein bisschen auf der seite umgucken die haben die haben wir noch viel mehr coole sachen
sehe das ganze was sehe das ganze smarter mit all die aus sicherheitsaspekten eher kritisch wie stehst du dazu sehe ich auch so deswegen mache ich auch selbst ich würde nie im leben auf die idee kommen da einen alexa oder den google home anzuschließen sofern der auf alles zugreifen dürfte also ich würde nie ein fertiges apple smart home apple google amazon smart home oder sowas verwenden was ich mache ist ich mache das selbst mit home assistant deswegen flash
ich ja auch alles deswegen lege ich ja auch so viel wert darauf dass die geräte die ich mir kaufe über so standardisierte schnittstellen ansprechbar sind deswegen ist mir das ja auch so wichtig und sollte ich mir mal einen alexa hinstellen übrigens wahrscheinlich wenn ich
demnächst mal wahrscheinlich werde ich demnächst mal das ausprobieren damit kann man sich mit dem raspberry pi einen voice assistant selbst bauen allerdings der kann natürlich standardmäßig nicht so viel und wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht so advanced sein wie alexa oder google oder so aber für 5 6 setze die man öfters brauchen die nervig sind mal gucken wie das funktioniert will ich in nächster zeit mal ausprobieren heimautomatisierung ist so ein ding wenn man einmal damit angefangen hat kann man
kann man nicht mal aufhören das show me camera league ja nicht nur das nicht nur das das ja pass mal auf ich weiß gar nicht ob ihr das schon ob ihr das mitbekommen habt die hatten in da hat jemand in seiner heimautomatisierung auf einmal die wohnung von anderen leuten gesehen
ja guckt euch das mal an der macht sein google der macht sein google home auf der macht sein google home auf drückt hier drückt ja auch cameras und auf einmal kriegt er ein bild angezeigt von einer fremden wohnung
ja fremde wohnung kriegt er angezeigt also das ist schon das ist schon richtig fäll deswegen stehe ich der sache auch kritisch gegenüber und ich mache es selbst wenn ich wenn ich selbst mache dann verkacke ich es wenigstens auch selbst aber nachdem man wenn man es selbst macht relativ genau was man macht bestehen solche chancen gar nicht weil das da solche sachen oder auch hier das das wisecam leak
das ist ja auch so ein ding gewesen hier personal data auf 2,4 millionen security camera konnte stream abgreifen das das da das passiert ja nur einzig und allein weil es ins internet geschickt wird zu irgendeinem anbieter was komplett hirnrissig ist wenn man sich mal genau überlegt wenn ich mein smart home also quasi ich möchte mein zuhause angenehmer für mich gestalten
und warum sollte ich mich quasi dann darauf verlassen dass irgendwelche leute in der cloud also ich muss quasi ich muss quasi die daten aus meinem haus rausschicken damit ich mein haus wieder steuern kann das ist einfach das ist einfach irrsinnig und irgendwie absurd deswegen verstehe ich auch die ganzen cloud lösungen nicht und man darf auch nicht vergessen man ist auf gedei und verderben von den herstellern abhängig
nest die wurden jetzt von google gekauft die haben thermostate gemacht die konntest du bis dahin relativ gut integrieren und mitten letzten jahres haben sie gesagt also die seitdem sie von google gekauft werden haben sie oh nee unsere api unsere api machen wir dicht und jetzt sitzen ganz viele leute da die haben ein nest thermostat zu hause und können es mit ihrer heim automatisierung nicht mehr anstreuen
das sei denn sie stellen alles was sie haben um auf google home was natürlich google geil findet und nachdem sich kein anbieter irgendwie mit rum bekleckert hat so nach dem motto wir schneiden voice assistant geschichten mit wir spielen voice assistant sachen vor natürlich nur um die qualität zu verbessern und solche sachen man kann der ganze sache total einfach aus dem weg gehen indem man es einfach selber macht wenn man es machen kann es ist manchmal es ist manchmal anstrengender ganz klar
aber du weißt halt auch genau was ist
also ja da würde ich da wäre ich also generell war fertigen smart hub geschichten was mehr war fertigen home automatisierung sowie apple home wie heißt das home kit und google home und was es da nicht alles gibt im leben würde ich mir das nicht daheim
hinstellen kann alexa integration machen ja das geht aber dann hat alexa auch nur zugriff auf das was ich haben will wenn man halt alexa haben möchte ne ne das das das kommt bei mir nicht hin also bei mir kommt nur was hin was ich selbst einrichten kann wir wollen
die prise war weiter weiter kickstarter kucke was hältst du von snips für smart home easy killer schön dass du fragst snips genau nächstes negativ beispiel snips war eine richtig gute gut richtig richtig guter voice assistant alternative für leute die gerne do it yourself basteln snips wurde jetzt gekauft von nicht sonov wie heißen sonos sonos
die wurden jetzt gekauft und selbst wird dicht wird dicht gemacht das heißt was man daran auch sieht man darf sich für die steuerung von seinem von seinem home nicht auf clouddisk zu verlassen ich kann mich noch an den thread auf reddit erinnern wo jemand rum aus canada wo jemand aus canada rumgeflammt hat dass er seine heizung nicht an mein in canada ist kalt seine heizung nicht anmachen kann weil sein internet ausgefallen ist und
das nest thermostat keine verbindung zur nest cloud hat ja schon kacke wenn den arsch abfrieren muss weil der thermostat nicht ins internet kommt und sowas sowas ist halt einfach nur idiotisch sowas sich überhaupt ins haus zu holen war bestimmt excusee ja der hat gesagt go again
wenn die neue home assistant vollstellung habe ich nicht ausprobiert die brauche aber auch teilweise home assistant cloud und sonst was und sie kann auch kein deutsch und das kann ich meine mutter auf keinen fall aufs
home assistant der nicht deutsch sprechen kann und es funktioniert auch noch nicht über die ios app also alles sachen die mich das nicht so attraktiv machen ich werde es mit respy ausprobieren als nächstes so ok was haben wir als nächstes was was gibt es hier noch schönes schönes den fingerbord hatten wir jetzt was halt rip-off ist von von von dem was ich euch gezeigt habe
von smartbord oh was haben die für stretchgoals ok integrate fingerbord mit stretchgoals 100k what the fuck alter guck mal die haben normal die wollten normal 18k und dann macht man als stretchgoal macht man nicht bei 25k sondern irgendwie gleich bei 100k smart things integration smart things ist genau so ein ding wie ich auch im leben verwendet verwenden fingerbord color wireless charging
sich wie wifi version das hier das ding sollte über irgendeine form von offenen standards offenen schittstellen steuerbar sein ansonsten ist es crap ok was haben wir als nächstes was mit me dry ein fön es ist ein fön einfach ein fön
ok dann fön
hast du sicherheits technische probleme mit ift ich verwende ift nicht ok dann fön
superspeed ultimate compactness also der griff ist schonmal doppelt so lang zumindest sieht es auf dem bild so aus wie von meinem billigen kleinen fön
hi iq ja schick schick schickst du mir im discord michael schickst du mir im discord und spam mich da ein bisschen voll also erst wenn ich gesagt habe ich hab's gesehen aufhören weil so über sehe ich das ok gucken wir uns mal an was ist das die hier so hat der alexa integrator werden wir gleich werden wir gleich feststellen
boah boah hotes grill beim haare föhnen
what the fuck
muss das sein warum immer diese na units warum immer diese na units was ist denn 30 mph
mps pro sekunde ok es ist 50 kmh ich hab keine ahnung was so normaler fön fön kmh außerdem ist das wahrscheinlich ziemlich egal
luftgeschwindigkeit von 208 luftgeschwindigkeit 120 km push ich weiß nicht ob das so entscheidend ist solange es genug ist wo ist er
ich glaub viel aerodynamischer ich glaub also ich mein so normaler fön da kann doch da ist da kann doch gar nicht viel aerodynamischer sein ich mein das geht hinten rein und bläst vorne raus was soll er
sein ich meine er kann vielleicht mehr luft ansaugen je nachdem wie viel wie viel luft ansauge dinger hier das hat aber dass der andere fön ist halt hinten komplett aus ist wieder da ist das ist scam aber ich hab nie gehört
guck mal als wäre das ein vorteil dass es ein knopf hat am besten ich bin ja jemand ich bin der meinung direktes feedback wenn man knöpfe drückt ist wichtig das heißt jetzt muss ich den knopf verschiedene
klickmuster mir merken dass ich weiß was niedrigmittel und hoch ist am besten wäre einfach den knopf mit drei stufen aus mittel an fertig
redefine herzweiger jetzt übertreibt das aber jetzt übertreibt das aber redefine herzweiger ja gut brauche ich nicht die hat aber eklige sachen in den haaren also wenn ich sowas in den haaren hätte da wenn sowas aus dem füll rauskommt
wo saugt das ding überhaupt luft an richtig wenn es das nicht hinten ansaugt sondern unten
gut was auch immer juckt mich überhaupt nicht das ist scam warum ist das scam wartet mal ja gut das sieht das sieht tatsächlich relativ ähnlich aus aber es kostet 63 euro das andere kostet
angeblich nur 50 euro das kann ja das andere gar kein so großer scam sein wenn es prinzipiell funktioniert was scam ist genau was einer freund geschrieben hat die wasserflasche die sich selbst auffüllt oder der regen wie hieß dieses regending noch mal
der wort water seer water seer kennt jetzt noch jemand der wort water seer das war auch scam das war huge scam der water seer ok guck mal was haben wir wall sun
fingerabdruck fingerabdruck fahrrad schloss guck mal der hat ein bisschen video der hat ein bisschen videosynchronisierungsprobleme guck mal mundbewegung an das wirkt sowieso eine schlecht nachsynchronisierte sitcom von früher guckt euch die mundbewegung an und dann was er sagt
so was sehe ich in frankfurt täglich
also es sieht nicht so stabil aus muss ich ehrlich gesagt
und was genau hindert jetzt jemand dran das fahrrad zu klauen
einmal ganz davon abgesehen ich glaube nicht dass man das sehr stabil bauen kann weil ich mein es muss beweglich sein es muss so beweglich sein dass es irgendwie automatisch entlocken kann also da ist irgendeine elektronik drinnen für das für das schloss also sprich ich muss ja für das schloss
also sprich ich muss ja fingerabdruck machen da muss es irgendwie aufgehen nachdem ich den finger muss irgendeine elektronik drin sein also an der stelle kann das schon mal gar nicht so super stabil sein und das sah jetzt auch nicht so stabil aus
und eventuell kann man sogar ganz easy knacken ja genau das kann ich nicht kann ich kann ich nichts zu sagen kann ich mich nicht aus aber das sieht nicht so aus als ist es so irgendwie so wahnsinnig stabil
zum thema fingerprint schloss ok gucken wir mal das ist aber kein schloss
ha ha schloss reibt sich auf monka toss
zufällig
falls right above the finger print sensor if you slide your finger down and press on the
sensor this clam shell pops open and the lock falls away that fast we got in that
sieht aber auch nicht stabil aus
so you can see it's very quick to access the gun
das ist das ist so eine richtige das ist so eine richtig typische kokona sache wieder
erst eine pistole kaufen damit der pistole rumlaufen aber dann ist es ja doof wenn man mit
der pistole rum läuft das dann auch theoretisch jeder an die pistole dran kann und dann macht
man ein schloss an die pistole das ist das ist typisch kokona logik
das bedeutet wir können ein bisschen einen schluss vergeben
man könnte ja auch alternativ keine pistole mitnehmen da kann auch keiner an die pistole
aber das ist es weil für viele Menschen die snelheit und entspannung mit der
defense of weapon can be accessed is everything in fact it's the reason that some people don't
use any lock at all so it is a decision between this
das ist das so besser mcree style aus der hüfte schießen kannst ohne lock
ob bmw bm nothing using this is an obvious improvement so what are the shortcomings first
it's very awkward for left-handed users
die kriegsten das vor allem in dessen in den holster da reichen
so da wird sich ein waffenschrank einfach anbieten daheim oder ist das eher weil man
weil man das auf dem nachttisch auf dem nachttisch liegen haben möchte und so dass die kinder
nicht dran können wenn es auf dem nachttisch liegt weil man braucht natürlich logischer
weise die pistole auf dem nachttisch
ok klingt sogar ganz sinnvoll wenn du schwitzt ist schlecht
ich bin ziemlich ziemlich aufgeregt und am schwitzen der scheiße meine pistole geht
nicht auf
moment erst mal durchatmen beruhigen finger trocken putzen und dann kannst du die einbrecher
erschießen
so for this reason i would really like to see a keypad backup so you don't need to search
for the backup keys if for some reason you can't use your fingerprint
for this is made out of what seems to be glass reinforced nylon which is a very strong material
at least as far as plastic scale however its rigidity is not great that means when you
twist a little bit you can see it's not too hard to access that trigger so you can imagine
a child prying on this with something thin
vor allem kannst du das wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut wenn ein schraubenzieher oder noch besser
gone freeman styled und brecheisen oder so
man könnte auch einfach wie es der rick sagt einfach den schlüssel im schloss drinnen
lassen
next level security
was passt da überhaupt nicht rein
king
of course it works perfectly
as
Die Dimple Locks können schnell geöffnet werden, wenn man mit hohen Geschwindigkeits-Attacken geht.
Das werden wir jetzt versuchen.
Jetzt kommt der nächste Level.
Und hier ist ein kleines Stück Metall.
Wir werden das als Dimple-Rake benutzen.
Okay, ihr seht, das war ziemlich schnell.
Die Frage bleibt, ob es ein Deal-Breaker ist.
Wenn du einer von diesen Menschen bist, der denkt, dass alle Locks zu langsam sind und dass deine Wahl zwischen dem und dem nichts ist,
dann ist das klar, dass das der Weg ist.
Jedoch, obwohl die Promisse von Design und Technologie vorhanden ist,
denke ich, dass es ein fairer Ort für Verbesserungen gibt.
In jedem Fall, das ist alles, was ich heute für euch habe.
Okay, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass es so einfach ist.
Okay, das wird wahrscheinlich mit dem Fahrradschloss ähnlich sein.
Weil das Fahrradschloss hat garantiert auch noch einen Schloss.
Weil es könnte ja mal sein, dass der Fingerabdrecksensor kaputt ist und das Fahrrad nicht mehr aufkommt.
Max, du glaubst gar nicht, wie viele Schlösser da schon geklackt haben.
Doch, glaube ich, weil der Channel heißt Lockpicking Lawyer.
Mit 1,2 Millionen Subs, der hat garantiert schon viele Schlösser geklackt.
Okay, was haben wir denn als nächstes? Joy Duo.
Ultra Portable USB-C Hub und Macbook.
Geht sowas bei Mac Leuten schon als Dockingstation durch?
Das wäre bei mir so ein Viertel von der Dockingstation.
Hi, was geht?
Ah, yes, Apple User.
Joy Duo ist nicht nur ein Hub.
Ah, Thunderbolt.
Also ja, USB-C.
Guck mal, das ist ein Fünftel von einer ordentlichen Dockingstation.
USB-C, das ist Thunderbolt an der Seite.
Aha.
Ach, deswegen auf beiden Seiten.
Wow.
Huge Acting, Leute.
Huge Acting.
Guckt euch mal an.
Wow.
Zwei Stück.
Ich muss sagen, keine schlechte Sache.
Finde ich gut unter der Voraussetzung, dass die anderen Hubs wirklich so kacke sind, wie er sagt.
Ich kenne mich mit Macbook, Macbook Dockingstations und sowas überhaupt nicht aus.
Was? 100 Watt?
Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das? 12 Volt?
12 Volt mit 5... Nee.
100? Was ist denn das?
24 Volt mit 5 Amp...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was da drüber geht.
32.
33 ist aber ganz schön schepp.
Jetzt muss ich mal ein bisschen über Apple Lester, ne?
Wenn man halt auch ein Notebook baut, was keine USB-Anschlüsse hat, dann braucht man sowas halt dabei.
Wenn man das Notebook dünner baut, um auf die letzten paar USB-Anschlüsse zu verzichten, müssen die Leute halt künstlich ihr Notebook dicker machen, um wieder an die USB-Anschlüsse zu bekommen.
Ein Volt und 100 Ampere.
Und wie lang ist das Kabel?
Wie lang darf das Kabel maximal sein?
Zwei Zentimeter.
Und ganz schön dick.
Ja gut, du hast es ja auch erfunden.
Also es sieht ziemlich hakelig aus, damit rum zu hantieren.
Quasi muss links dran docken, rechts dran docken.
Wie wäre es mit einer ganz normalen Docking-Station?
Ich finde es sinnvoll. Also alles, was wir bis heute gesehen haben, das ist das Sinnvollste bisher.
Das Werk hat sich angehört wie ein Warcraft 3-Worker, oder?
Werk, Werk, Werk, Werk.
Ein bisschen ähnlich geil, oder?
Ein bisschen, ein bisschen.
Ja, warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Das ist, oh alter.
Die Apple-Leute.
Den kannst du alles verkaufen.
Ja, also.
Wir müssten ein Kickstarter-Projekt machen, keine Ahnung.
Steve Jobs linker Socken wurde jetzt gefunden.
Und wir haben ihn quasi mit einem 3D-Drucker 50 Millionen mal ausgedruckt.
Und wir verkaufen jetzt Steve Jobs linken Socken.
Und dann machen wir einen Apple-Kickstarter und das geht ab wie sonst was.
Ich finde es ein bisschen umständlich, dass du damit zwei Sachen rumhantieren musst, mobil.
Zumal, zumal, guckt mal, mobil brauchst du in der Regel kaum Anschlüsse.
Willst du es als Desktop-Ersatz verwenden, dann könnte man doch sich einfach eine ganz normale Docking-Station hinstellen.
Wahrscheinlich ist die Docking, gibt es überhaupt MacBook-Docking? Gibt es sowas?
Ja, warum nicht einfach sowas?
Na ja, keine Ahnung.
Aber das macht einen ganz sinnvollen Eindruck.
Up to 40 GB Stata, gut, äh, theoretisch.
In der Theorie, ja. In der Theorie.
5K, 60 FPS.
Okay, ist bestimmt ganz sinnvoll.
Muss ich zugeben, ich will es jetzt nicht zu schlecht reden, kann durchaus was Sinnvolles sein.
Ich meine, ist jetzt nichts super herausragendes oder so, aber warum nicht?
Wirklich, wirklich günstiger als die anderen Docking-Stations, das ist jetzt auch nicht.
Ähm, Januar Mass Production, aha, aha, aha.
Schauen wir mal, was so die Kommentare sagen, ob das denn überhaupt im Zeitplan liegt.
Es gab noch keine Updates.
Noch keine Updates seit einem Monat und im Januar soll die Mass Production anfangen.
Und die ersten Leute sind schon am Flamen, dass sie irgendwas nicht sehen.
40 GB File Transfer, das will ich sehen.
Wie macht er 40 GB File Transfer? Wo gibt's das?
Ähm, das will ich sehen. Wo stand's hier?
Wo gibt's das Video?
Test Video Part, okay, okay.
Ah hier, File Transfer Speeds.
40 GB, da bin ich mal gespannt, mir fällt ja nämlich nichts ein, mit was man das machen soll, aber schauen wir mal.
Oh, das ist ja mal ein Huge-Brain-Benchmark-Programm.
What?
Was seh ich da überhaupt? Kann man da noch ein bisschen mehr, noch ein bisschen pixeliger machen bitte?
Weißt du, wenn MacBook Pro haben und sonst was, aber keine gescheite Kamera.
Das zeigt mir aber keine 40 GB, das zeigt mir 430 MBit.
Okay, das wird absolut nichts sagen.
Okay, weiter im Text.
Für ein Screen-Capture-Programm war kein Geld mehr da, das ist schon teuer, wenn man so eine tolle Docking-Station war.
Was haben wir hier? 8 Bit Warps, 8 Bit Web, irgendein Musik-Ding.
Definitiv nichts für mich, aber man weiß ja nie, vielleicht ist ja für euch was dabei.
Wow.
DJ Grill.
Draußen haben wir Musik. Geht das überhaupt als Musik durch?
Okay.
Gut, man weiß ja nie, für wen das ist.
Vielleicht ist das viel geiler, als es für mich aussieht, als unwissender, was Musik angeht.
Die geht ja richtig ab an dem Teil.
Ja, okay.
Was hältst du von Oscilloskop-Musik, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Sonic, Japan, also ein Ayaya-Produkt.
Okay, ich weiß nicht wofür man es braucht, aber ich weiß nicht, dass es schlecht sein muss.
So, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht.
Flash-Forest. Was? Using Drones to Plant 1 Billion.
Mit Drohnen?
Ich weiß ja nicht, okay.
Huge success hier?
What?
Artificial intelligence? What? Ich konnte dem Satz nicht folgen.
Ein AI-Trieb?
Ich glaube, allein mit Bäume pflanzen ist es nicht getan. Es ist keine schlechte Sache.
Aber man müsste vielleicht erstmal ein bisschen weniger die Umwelt verschmutzen. Das wäre schon mal ein guter Ansatz.
Vielleicht sollten wir auch mal dafür sorgen, dass man nicht von einem Satellitenbild quasi komplett eigene Landmassen erkennen kann, um dann festzustellen, ach nee, das ist ja einfach nur ein riesen Kontinent, quasi fast schon ein Plastik, der im Meer schwimmt.
Ja, wie pflanzen die denn die Bäume überhaupt?
Hat man das überhaupt nicht gesehen, oder? Haben die das gesagt? Werfen die da irgendwie Samen ab, oder? Wie pflanzen die Dinger?
Die werfen diese Kugeln ab da. Die schießen das.
Die schießen das. Ach, die schießen das in die Erde, oder was? Das ist quasi so eine Softair, also nee, eher so ein bisschen größere Softair.
Ach, da schießt die Krabbe in die Erde.
Das ist wieder so ein Ding, was echt cool klingt.
Aber ich glaube, wenn man da in Ruhe drüber nachdenkt, glaube ich, kommt man auf jede Menge Schwierigkeiten, die der Sache im Weg stehen.
Es klingt erstmal cool, aber ich denke, umso mehr man sich da Gedanken drüber macht, umso mehr Schwachstellen wird man da allein schauen, ohne großartig in die Details zu gehen drinne finden.
Aber ich gehe davon aus, dass das tatsächlich mal ein Projekt ist, dass die Leute zumindest, die man da im Video sieht und die das Projekt durchführen, dass die das zumindest als Überzeugung machen, dass das was Gutes ist.
Wenn wir den Klimawandel aufhalten, wird es garantiert nicht, wenn da ein paar Drohnen rumfliegen und Dings in den Boden schießen.
Aber warum nicht? Ja, zum Beispiel das erste, was mir einfällt, so eine Drohne zu bauen, die Batterien, das ganze Zeug, müsste man sich jetzt mal überlegen, das was man dafür braucht, ob das die Anzahl an Bäumen, ich weiß es nicht, keine Ahnung.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Ich glaube aber, dass es einige Probleme hat, die letztendlich dazu führen werden, dass es sich nicht so super rentiert, wie man vielleicht denkt.
Ich meine, die wollen 150.000 Bäume pflanzen, das könntest du einfacher haben, oder? 150.000 Bäume pflanzen, da einfach mal auf gehts. Wenn die alle ihre Leute nehmen und jedem quasi eine Pistole in die Hand drücken, um die Dinger in die Boden zu ballern, laufen die durch die Bäume durch, durch die Wälder durch und ballern aus Zeug in die Erde, dann sind die schneller fertig, als sie das gebaut haben.
Okay, aber warum nicht? Wenigstens eine nette Idee.
So, was haben wir hier als nächstes?
Das ist was für mich. Das ist was für mich. Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Ah, yes, excellent. Ups, nein, das wollte ich haben, excellent. Warum habe ich meinen Scheißhaufen E-Mode direkt über excellent?
So wie der doof das ist dass ich mir also komplett in zwei lager gespalten hat ja du hast zumindest kommt einem das sofort es
Gibt bestimmt auch noch genug leute in der mitte aber das was du hörst du hast so zwei lager du hast so einmal die die quasi sagen
Oh hier seid man nicht so hysterisch hier klima so kann der mensch ja eh nix für sonst was du hast die anderen
Die die am liebsten quasi alles erschießen würden was nicht den greta poster aufgehängt hat
Aber ich finde man muss man muss doch mal gucken dass es also es sollte jedem klar sein dass es so nicht weitergehen kann
und
Man sollte sich auch nicht nur auf eine sache fokussieren zum beispiel was ich gerade gesagt habe muss man gucken wie viel plastik im mehr mittlerweile
rumspringt rumschwimmt und solche sachen
generell muss man ein bisschen hin dazu hin
Kriegen kriegen oder die kurve kriegen dass wir überhaupt mit allem die umwelt weniger verschmutzen
Es geht nicht
Es wird sich so sehr auf ganze co2 geschichte sonst war es fokussiert
Ich sage nicht dass es verkehrt ist oder schlecht wäre aber wir haben auch sehr viele andere
Baustellen wo wir uns mal ein bisschen zusammenreißen müssen
Ich weil man sieht das man sieht von satelliten bildern aus plastik im mehr
Leider ist es wieder so ein ding
Wo auch wieder so ein thema wo wir es wieder nicht schaffen ordentlich drüber zu diskutieren wie gesagt die einen schreien rum so nach dem motto seid nicht
So hysterisch dass es ja alles halb so wild und der mensch kann da eh nix dafür
Wie man überhaupt auch so eine idee kommen kann finde ich abweg ich aber die andere seite
ist ist auch nicht auch nicht besser du musst bei allen sachen gucken die du machst dass du es irgendwie schaffst zumindest die leute
halbwegs mit abzuholen und halbwegs mit zu überzeugen
Ansonsten willst du so viel widerstände aufstände sonst was kriegen
Und man muss ja auch schauen dass es nicht gerade die aus baden müssen die eh schon fandflaschen sammeln müssen am hauptbahnhof
Am hauptbahnhof
Weil kommen eigentlich die neuen emote bald
Okay, wir gucken sie jetzt die raspberry pi selbst duet yourself remote an
Die
Gibt es ein video
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein altes klappen die oder so ein altes so kennt ihr noch die leute die früher das klappen die
Nicht mit dem daumen aufgeklappt haben sondern so cool so cool aus dem handgelenk so beim aufflippen konnten das fand ich immer
Nice, das hatte so was, so was stylishes.
Du hast das Klab-Handy nicht aufgeklappt mit dem Daumen, sondern hast du aufgeschüttelt das Klab-Handy.
Okay, Boomer, Leute, chat, jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht von euch.
Ich rede über Klab-Handys, das ist die Gelegenheit.
Chat, ich warte da jetzt drauf, das ist die Gelegenheit,
dass ihr das mal wieder loswerden könnt, weil ich bin eh mal in 35. Ja, gut, wunderbar.
Es gibt doch wieder Klab-Smartphones, ja, gibt's jetzt wieder, und es wird keine Sau kaufen,
weil es übelst teuer ist und nicht wirklich großartig was bringt, aber sobald Apple rauskommt
und bringt ein Klab-Handy, dann wird's voller Erfolg.
Jetzt muss erst mal Apple mit einem neuen Klab-Handy rauskommen, dann geht's ab.
Wobei selbst Apple kein Garant dafür ist, man gucke sich mal Apple Watch an.
Apple Watch, ja. War damals auch gehypt, vorgestellt und im Endeffekt,
außer für ein bisschen Fitness-Trackern, werden die ganzen Geschichten nicht verwendet.
Das-der-ist fragt, ich weiß nicht, ob die Frage schon gestellt wurde, wenn du so anfängst,
garantiert, aber sollte man jetzt wirklich Windows 7 als Privatperson ersetzen,
oder ist das egal, wenn man eh den gleichen PC seit sieben Jahren hat?
Ja, auf jeden Fall solltest du das ersetzen.
Michael, es gibt einen Emote-Channel, da kannst du es reinschreiben.
Ähm, auf jeden Fall, Windows 7 muss weg.
Windows 7 muss weg.
Äh, ich dachte, wir kriegen jetzt so ein fancy Intro-Video.
Wo ist denn da der Raspberry drin? Das ist ein Zero, oder?
Das könnte man bisher aber auch alles ohne Probleme mit einem ESP machen.
Ein Zero ist da drin, okay.
Ach, der ist das, das hab ich gesehen. Den Forum-Post hab ich gesehen.
Das kenn ich, das hab ich mir schonmal angeguckt vor einem Jahr.
Ach, der ist das. Das war wirklich ganz cool.
Aber ich dachte, da hat irgendwie ein cooles Video gedreht, oder so, mittlerweile.
Das find ich von der Idee, ah, hier.
Nee.
Das heißt, das hat auch Erkennung, wann sich einer sich benährt.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, aber die Sache ist die, es braucht keiner mehr Fernbedienung.
Ich hab meine Dashboard-Tablets, wenn ich was steuern muss.
Das Einzige halt für den Fernseher, aber ansonsten, ich glaube...
Also wenn ich wirklich Home-Automatisieren übersteuern würde,
nehm ich eines der 14 Tablets, die so rumfliegen.
Das funktioniert garantiert nicht besser, wie in den Harmony-Hub,
oder wie in den Logitech Harmony, weil's Do-It-Yourself ist.
Und die Dinger können in der Regel standardmäßig nicht so viel.
Sondern, sie sind halt, der Vorteil ist halt, dass sie individuell anpassbar sind.
Das Open Source würd ich mal vermuten, ja.
Ja.
Ja, ja, ist es, ist es.
Ich hab das Projekt im Home Assistant Forum schon vor einem Jahr gesehen.
Hier.
Touch Remote, GitHub.
100 Sterne für so Nischenprojekts nicht verkehrt.
Leute, ich muss mal ganz kurz...
Affk.
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Ja.
Ich...
Und Chat.
Ich beobachte euch vom Handy aus.
Kein Scheiß machen.
Affk.
Ja.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
.
So, auf geht's!
Was macht das?
Das ist auch ordentlich formatiert.
Ich habe das eins zu eins von Stack Overflow kopiert und ich habe legit keine Ahnung,
was es macht.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Ich weiß, was rauskommt, ich habe aber keine Ahnung, was es macht.
Was ist das?
Was macht das?
Jedes Mal, wenn ich etwas C++-mäßiges suchen muss, was ganz einfaches.
Wenn ich denke, es muss doch recht easy sein und dann suche ich danach, wie man Sachen
in C++ macht.
Und das erste, was ich finde, sind Stack Overflow-Einträge, wo Leute irgendwelche
Hacks vorschlagen, weil die einfachsten Sachen nicht ordentlich funktionieren, dieser
Kack-Sprache.
Es ist die beschissenste Programmiersprache auf dieser, naja, okay, es gibt Schlimmere,
aber eine der schlimmsten Programmiersprachen ever.
Lieber zwei Zeilen mehr und übersichtlich, ich mache es übersichtlicher.
Also, Chat, ich sehe auch, ihr habt keine Ahnung, vor allem, was zum Geier ist das hier?
Ich kapiere ja alles, das hier ist die Zeile, die ich nicht verstehe.
C++ ist so eine hässliche Ausgeburt der Hölle mittlerweile.
Du guckst, du suchst dir einfache Sachen raus und musst erst mal 20 Seiten Template schreiben
in C++.
So eine Kack-Sprache.
Ich wollte es euch noch mal zeigen, weil das richtig eklig ist.
Geh weg.
Ekliges Zeug.
Kannst du den Code kopieren und oder einen Link für Schöne...
Was da rauskommt, das ist schwierig zu erklären ohne den Kontext.
Kann ich so nicht erklären.
Guckst du dir so Zeug an, wenn du kackst?
Nee.
Also ehrlich gesagt, gerade wo ich kacken war, habe ich mir den Twitch-Chat angeguckt,
weil ich wissen wollte, was der Chat macht, während ich weg bin.
Den Code kann man nicht ausführen, das ist ein Template, das eine Funktion anlegt, die
noch aufgerufen werden muss.
Ansonsten, ich habe noch eine riesen Stapel CTs liegen, die ich mal lesen müsste.
Ich habe ja ein CT-Abo seit Jahren, also wirklich 15 Jahre, ewig habe ich ein CT-Abo, ewig,
wirklich ewig.
15 Jahre, locker habe ich ein CT-Abo und ich lese davon nichts, die stapeln sich einfach
nur.
Die ist uns vor.
Warum da noch ein Abo?
Tja, weil ich zu faul gewesen ist, zu kündigen bisher.
Ich habe noch eine GameStar-CD von 1997.
Okay, weiter geht's.
Power and Endurance.
What the fuck?
Was ist das?
Man kann damit alte Sachen wieder neu machen?
Soll das das heißen?
Okay, ich bin ja mal gespannt.
Alte Getriebe.
Ja, erst mal eines der größten Projekte der Menschheitsgeschichte, so, ja.
Ah, Kona.
Super Lubricity.
Das klingt falsch, was das klingt falsch, was der sagt.
Was?
Na ja...
Planes are built to last, thank you.
But the key to dependability is upgrading components over time.
Today we use the same aviation grade lube that was made when MASH was on the air.
We're gonna let them do this to us? No, I say, no! We want something else!
Here's where you come in. Partner with us and the United States Air Force to take a quantum leap forward
and formulate the most advanced gearbox lubricant for flying machines.
Also, wenn die gefundet sind von der Air Force, dann sollte ein bisschen mehr Geld drin sein, oder?
Dann müssen wir nicht auf Kickstarter.
Seit wann holt sich die Air Force für Flugzeugwartung Geld von Kickstarter?
Gearbox failure is a nightmare for pilots, aircraft mechanics and everyday people.
A dead transmission costs you thousands of dollars, even if you can repair it yourself.
It will take us a few years to get the flight ready, but we're bringing the same technology to automotive vehicles today.
Because you don't have to fly your car to need a reliable...
Ich warte noch drauf, dass sie uns erzählen, wie es funktioniert.
Ja, genau! Screw 6, genau das denke ich mir auch gerade.
Die sollen uns mal erzählen, wie das funktioniert.
That's why we're releasing an ATF treatment that restores your gearbox to a better than new condition
with diamond-like gamma on critical components forged by carbon under the heat and pressure of the drivetrain.
Just like our original engine treatment, Tribotec's transmission uses full-sided nanoparticles to protect vulnerable surfaces.
The grippy side binds your machine to protect and strengthen.
The slippery side reduces friction to super-lubricity levels, enhancing performance and efficiency.
This powerful little particle won the 2017 Defense Innovation Award, the 2018 Indiegogo Innovative Product Award
and an Air Force SBIR Phase 1 Award.
Tribotec's already offers engine treatment.
Ich hab davon kein Plastenschimmer.
Aber so wirklich eine Erklärung für Leute, die es becken wollen, die aber sich nicht einfach nur mit abspeisen lassen, das ist das beste Ever, wäre schon nicht schlecht.
Also, erklärt uns doch mal, wie es geht.
For all kind of machines, whether you drive a motorcycle, hybrid or 18-wheeler, you can be more efficient.
In fact, Tribotec isn't just for engines and machines. Friction is a problem that affects everyone.
From the machines we depend on, we can build a big machine back on campaign and together we'll advance lubrication with a new millennium
and make our world more efficient, more powerful and more sustainable.
You do not have to fly to use this technology.
But with your help, we will take it to the sky above and beyond.
Tribotec, it's backed by science, backed by you.
Okay, backed by science, wenn ich das reinschreiben muss, klingt schon nach Scam.
Also, wenn jemand das Video mit backed by science und im Prinzip nichts erzählt darüber.
Diamond-like armor.
Made in Kokona, okay.
Ah, ich weiß ja nicht.
Also, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte zwischen linker Bildhälfte und rechter Bildhälfte,
dann wäre das ja noch ein Deal irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube, so wirklich lasse ich das nicht an mein Auto ran.
Wobei mein Auto...
Ich sehe alles verloren, ja.
Okay, next.
Fernbedienung Hammer.
City-Maps, das braucht kein Mensch, das interessiert mich nicht.
Oh je.
Projekte gehen eigentlich in der...
So Projekte gehen eigentlich immer in die Hose, aber das müssen wir uns trotzdem mal angucken.
Hast du was zu Thunderbolt 4 gelesen? So ein Boot? Nee, nee. Warum?
Sollte Thunderbolt jetzt nicht in USB einfließen und Thunderbolt wegfallen mit USB 4?
Nee, kein Fiat. Ich habe euch doch schon mal mein huge Auto gezeigt.
Ja.
Beste.
Grün.
Gut. Es ist für die Klasse tatsächlich gut.
Ja, schon diese Farbe hier.
Ich war schon Agile, bevor das angesagt war.
Kennzeichen liegt. GG.
Thanks, Ray.
Leider habe ich nicht mitgekriegt. Und zu Thunderbolt 4 habe ich auch nichts gelesen.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt den...
Foldable Self-Balancing Scooter an.
Das sind so diese Kickstarter-Projekte, wo ich mir immer so denke, ja, selbst wenn am Ende was Fertiges rauskommt,
meistens sind nicht das... Mir fallen wenig Beispiele ein, wo diese Sachen immer erfolgreich gewesen sind.
Das größte Negativbeispiel ist nicht aus dieser Branche, aus der anderen ist ja immer noch Star Citizen.
Wie steht es so um Star Citizen? Ich habe gehört, 2020 erscheint angeblich die Kampagne.
Es gibt nicht viele richtig erfolgreiche Kickstarter-Sachen in der Größe hier.
IP-Leak. Wo denn jetzt schon wieder? Hier, irgendwo. IP-Leak.
Da, IP-Leak. Oh, shit.
Fuck, Alter. IP-Leak.
OMG-IP-Leak. Wenn man auf diese IP-Leak liegt, kommt man in meinem Memeboard raus.
So sieht das aus, wenn ich vom zweiten Monitor aus bediene.
Ihr seht das bloß immer nicht.
Kennst du Crowd Supply? Die habe ich schon nicht angeguckt.
Hotkeys habe ich auch, zum Beispiel M, L, S, G. Nee, G habe ich nicht mehr. Nicht so viel.
Ok, das Self-Balancing Scooter. Also, hast du das Dashboard im Stream programmiert? Ein bisschen.
Teilweise haben wir im Stream gemacht.
Ich meine, man könnte auch einfach sich einen normalen E-Roller holen und das einfach an einem Fahrradständer abstellen oder so.
Geht auch.
Überlegt euch mal, ihr wollt in Saturn rein und habt so ein Ding dabei.
Die lassen euch da nicht rein. Die haben ja eh komplette Paranoia beim Saturn am Eingang.
Habt ihr euch das mal aufgefallen? Egal, was du mit reinnehmen willst, wollen sie dich nicht mit reinnehmen lassen.
Und ich lasse meinen Rucksack mit Inhalten, da ist nicht irgendwelchen Security-Menschen.
Wieso auch in Saturn wollen sie das eigentlich? Kackler.
Der hat aber laufen geübt, oder? Der läuft sehr cool und lässig mit diesem Ding, oder? Guckt euch das mal an.
Pass mal auf jetzt. Guck mal. Jetzt hier. Guck mal, wie cool er da mit lang läuft.
Oh, immer diese Kakao-Units.
Was sind denn zwölf Meilen?
Die Reifen sind ziemlich klein. Die Reifen sind ziemlich klein und dünn.
Deswegen sieht das auch so wackelig aus.
Bei uns in Frankfurt stehen an jeder Ecke so Dinge rum zu mieten.
Die sind eigentlich ganz cool. Aber die erhöhen, du kannst quasi zugucken, wie die, nicht nur Leimroller, es gibt drei Stück, die da rumstehen.
Es gibt so Orange, es gibt Grüne und es gibt Blau, Gelbe.
Das ist noch mal ganz nice. Aber du kannst quasi zugucken, wie der da nicht teurer wird.
Okay, das ist schon ganz schön wackelig.
Das da oben bricht ab. Guckt euch das mal an. Das bricht ab. Guckt mal. Das bricht ab.
Da mal ordentlich dran gerüttelt, wenn es das mal ordentlich durchrüttelt, wenn mal irgendwie was ist.
Manchmal, wenn du fliegst aufs Maul oder du fährst gegen so ein Bordschirm, das bricht ab.
Da oben. Gerade da auch, wo das Gelenk ist.
Ich ahle dir, dann bricht es vielleicht nicht ab und dann verbiegt es sich, so dass du nichts mehr mitmachen kannst.
Also das sieht nicht so stabil aus.
Generell sieht es halt aus, als wäre es auf fancy Optik gemacht.
Die können viel sagen, wenn der Tag lang ist. Das sieht nicht stabil aus hier oben. Das ganze Ding.
Ist mehr wert als ein Opel, garantiert. Für meinen Opel muss ich noch Geld bezahlen, wenn ihn jemand nimmt.
Man2X ist einzigartig und erstaunlich für den E-Scooter-Markt.
Wir produzieren die erste Maschine von Man2X. Unser Team wächst jeden Tag.
Bitte zurück in unsere Kampagne und hilf uns, diese fantastische Innovation in die Welt zu zeigen.
Ich habe den Wahnsinnsvorteil zu einem herkömmlichen E-Roller noch nicht erkannt.
Damit fährst du ja nicht durch die Stadt.
Da fährst du damit hin, wo du hin willst.
Und dann kannst du ihn ja immer noch beispielsweise an irgendeinem Fahrradständer festmachen.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, ob das gescheit funktioniert.
Was kostet der?
339 Dollar, das ist ganz schön billig.
Das ist ziemlich günstig.
Was kostet so ein ordentlicher E-Roller?
Wie heißt er? Elektro-Roller.
Das sind eher die Preise, in denen wir uns bewegen.
Wie sieht denn die zeitliche Abfolge aus?
Wo steht es denn?
Wo steht es denn, wenn die fertig sind?
März 20, das ist ja nicht mal lang.
100 Kilo Maximum Payload.
Leute, es wird eng.
Erstmal auf die Waage stellen.
Es wird eng.
Asien, kein Problem.
Das hier oben sieht null stabil aus.
Das ist jetzt zum 25. Mal.
Mal gucken.
Okay, was haben wir als nächstes?
Ist das nicht normal, dass man Entfernung mittlerweile mit Laser misst?
Das sieht aus wie Aliexpress.
Diese Musik immer.
Was?
Ist das, wenn ich mit zwei Leuten kommunizieren will?
Ich habe abgenommen, weil ich heute nichts gegessen habe.
Versteht man sehr gut, oder?
Ich denke, ihr versteht auch alles.
Alles klar.
Es ist doch Aliexpress.
So etwas gibt es doch schon.
Das ist doch nichts Neues.
Es ist eine der Werkzeuge, die ich noch nicht besitze.
Aber sowas gibt es doch schon.
Seid mal hier, Link, Chat.
Ja, genau, sowas im Prinzip.
Ich finde diese Bosch-Bilder immer so geil.
Haben sie irgendeinen Typ hingestellt?
Nach dem Motto, zieh dir mal einen Blaumann an und dann machen wir mal ein schönes Foto.
Sie hätten diesen Ha-Ha-Typ nehmen müssen.
Diese mit den weißen Haaren, der so grinst.
Wie heißt denn der?
Der Meme-Opa.
Ja, Harald, Harald, genau, genau der.
Den meine ich.
Na ja.
Okay, da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt.
Das ist ja ein sehr vollmundiges Versprechen.
Ich meine, es ist quasi eine Notebook-Halterung, wo man ein iPad reinklipsen kann.
Dadurch wird das iPad noch lange nicht zur MacBook Pro.
Aber mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken, was wir uns erzählen wollen.
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen, China, AliExpress, können wir es bestellen demnächst.
Doku, Doko, Dokyo.
Kann das nicht mal ausspringen.
Erst mal schön programmieren ohne Syntax-Highlighting.
Das müssen wir mal genauer analysieren, Leute.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine hässliche Editor?
Void, Z-Display, Capable.
Virtual Void, das ist C++.
Das ist C++ und dann auch noch ohne Syntax-Highlighting.
Das sieht nicht nach Arduino-Zeugs aus.
Also wie der 5G über USB 3.0 kriegen will, das will ich sehen.
Das will ich sehen, never.
Geht gar nicht.
Gar nicht drin.
Also von der Bedienung her ist es glaube ich mit Tastatur richtig kacke.
Ich habe das ja mal ausprobiert.
Eine Tastatur geholt fürs iPad.
Lohnt sich null.
Ich habe gedacht, das ist ganz praktisch, wenn man ein bisschen was längeres drauf tippen will.
Es ist voll für den Arsch.
Es ist komplett wasted.
Und das wahrscheinlich auch.
Kriegst nie im Leben 5 Gigabit über USB 3.0.
Nie.
480 ist das Maximum, was theoretisch geht.
3.0 und das ist auch nur theoretisches USB-Maximum.
Und das ist in...
Ach so 480 sind 2.
Du kriegst trotzdem kein 5 Gigabit über USB 3.0.
Kein Fall.
Nie und nimmer.
Ja.
Guck, du kriegst... Moment.
Das ist einmal eins.
Du kriegst 5 Gigabit.
Da hast du maximale, im optimalsten Fall, USB-Geschwindigkeit.
Und da kriegst du im Leben keine 5 Gigabit drüber.
Im Leben nicht.
Da kannst du locker nochmal ein Drittel abziehen von.
Ja gut, natürlich, ich kann...
Ich kann ein Port dran machen, der 5G Link bekommt irgendwie, ja.
Aber da nicht 5G übertragen.
Lest da drunter, was soll ich lesen?
Hier.
Super Speed USB.
Gut, das heißt ja noch nichts.
Das ist was du damit maximal theoretisch machen könntest.
Aber das ist quasi, wenn du 1 zu 1 Bits von A nach B ohne jegliche Protokolle, ohne jegliche andere Sachen übertragen könntest.
Kannst du ja nicht.
Das kriegst du nie, kriegst du nie im Leben drüber über 3.0.
USB 3.0 Maximum SSD.
Gucken wir mal.
Gibt's da, gibt's da, gibt's da irgendeinen Test für?
Slower than Sata, ja auf jeden Fall.
Ja, Chip.
Die Seite meines Vertrauens.
Das ist aber kein 2x2.
Test.
Ja, Chip.
Hallo?
Tabelle.
Tom's Hardware, das geht ja noch.
Wir müssen halt gucken, dass es auch USB 3.0 ist.
Alter, mach doch einfach, mach doch irgendjemand mal ne Tabelle dahin.
So.
Und das ist schon ne neuere.
500 Gigabit, also Taschenrechner.
Das ist 1 Gigabit mal 5.
So, 625 gehen, 400 geht durch.
Ja, jetzt rede ich mal nicht raus.
Du hast gesagt, kein Problem.
Und jetzt sagst du, braucht man doch nicht.
Ich sag, geht nicht.
Das theoretische Max, das ist ein bisschen wie bei PCI Express.
PCI Express geht auch viel, viel mehr als theoretisch dann wirklich an Daten nutzbar drüber geht.
Das ist, wenn du Netzwerkkarten oder sonst was über USB machst, auch so.
So, gucken wir mal weiter, wie die das iPad zum MacBook machen.
Oh, man kann das chargern, das geht ja so gar nicht.
Das ist noch schneller, jetzt sind wir bei USB 3.1.
Ja, Flow 690, exakt das gleiche sag ich doch auch.
Du hast am Anfang gesagt, das packt 5 Gigabit.
Packt das nicht.
400 Megabyte sind keine 5 Gigabit.
Das kann man ganz einfach umrechnen.
5 Gigabit sind irgendwie 650 und keine 400.
Touchpad, nein, ich weiß nicht.
Also, ich behaupte mal, es ist komplett useless das Ding.
Eiskräuter ist doch ganz einfach, USB 3.0 ist das gleiche wie USB 3.2.1x1.
Oh, guck mal, der guckt Witcher.
Das Witcher.
Das ist komplett useless das Ding.
Das ist für Netflix Copyright Strike, genau.
Nee, das ist wirklich komplett useless gewesen.
Nee, Hosen, nein, nach dem Scam, wo sie mich mit der Hose gescampt haben,
noch mal bestelle ich mir keine Hose bei Kickstarter.
Der Ananas Stepper, das könnte praktisch sein.
Zum Beispiel für Fensterblenden oder...
Für was kann man es gebrauchen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Hosen-Scam, ja, ich habe mal für 150 Dollar keine selbstreinigende Jeans,
sondern eine Jeans gebacked, die quasi wasserabweisende Partikel drin hat.
Und deswegen nicht so schnell dreckig wird und halt keine Flecken drin bleiben.
Und die wurde halt nie ausgeliefert.
Der Ananas Stepper.
Ah, für 3D-Drucker.
Nee, wollte er, die habe ich noch nicht probiert.
Und Fräse.
Ach, dafür ist das da, okay.
Huge Voice Acting.
Aber guten Namen hat es, guten Namen hat es, muss ich bei Ihnen lassen.
Der Ananas Stepper.
Sieht aus wie ein von mir...
Sieht aus wie ein von mir zusammengelötetes Board, Alter.
Nein, es sieht besser aus, aber hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wovon er spricht.
Aber das liegt an mir, nicht an ihm.
Wahrscheinlich ist das für Leute, die wissen, was sie brauchen, was richtig cool ist.
Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, von was er spricht.
Slap.
Das ist SMD, keine Lutsch-Stelle.
Haben sie mit dem Föhn drauf gemacht, mit dem Eisluft-Föhn.
Ananas Stepper, ich mag den Namen, der gefällt mir.
Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, wozu ich den Ananas Stepper gebrauchen könnte.
Und ich habe hier schon viel Automatisierungsgedöns, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe bisher den Ananas Stepper, habe ich so noch nicht erkannt, dass ich den brauche.
Der Name ist toll, brauchen die noch Geld?
Nee, brauchen die nicht, okay. Ananas Stepper.
Heißt es nicht Pineapple, in dem Fall heißt es Ananas.
Xbox Ananas, würden die ihre Xbox Ananas nennen?
Die würden sich verkaufen wie wenigstens wie die PS5 in Deutschland.
Das ist Visual Studio Code.
Und das könnte jetzt, das ist C, das ist normales C.
Sieht zumindest von der Syntax her so aus, ohne irgendwas drumherum.
Könnte aber auch was anderes sein.
Hier ist es C++, hier ist Cpp.h. Eigentlich ist es egal.
Das habe ich so auch noch nicht gehört.
Okay, Flo690 ist geforscht.
Moment, Moment.
Siehste, jetzt habe ich das Beste wieder nicht gesehen.
Noch, Thinking Emoji.
Warum nicht, es geht.
Twitch Prime, HiHo2. Danke schön, huge Prime-Sub.
Der Name ist geil.
Der Name ist geil, Ananas Stepper.
Und das Video ist auch cool. Endlich war ein cooles Produkt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wozu ich es jemals gebrauchen könnte.
Aber das gefällt mir.
Ist das eine Computerstimme?
Habe ich auch gedacht, zwischendurch.
Aber Computerstimmen haben in der Regel keine Zune Nase.
Und keine Computerstimmen klingen ohne Beeinträchtigung.
Es klingt aber ein bisschen wie ein Text-to-Speech.
Weil es auch Raspberry Pi gesagt hat und C++.
Ananas Stepper, huge.
Ich weiß nicht, wozu ich es brauche.
Aber Ananas Stepper ist nice.
Perfekt, next.
Unbeatable.
Dünne Kopfhörer mit Supreme Sound Quality.
Also eine Sache muss man ja bei Lautsprechern...
Man kann Lautsprecher in einer Sache ganz gut mit Autos vergleichen.
Größe sagt tatsächlich etwas aus.
Raum ist da bei Lautsprechern durch noch mehr Raum zu ersetzen.
Ok, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Kickstarter Musik.
Was ist 0,1 Odds?
Ist das wieder Kokona-Einheit?
Ounces? Sind das Ounces?
Ok, machen wir es einfach zu Gramm.
2, also 3 Gramm. 3 Gramm.
Ounces, meine Güte ey.
Diese Einheiten.
Ah yes.
Also 3 Gramm.
Sehr dünn.
Ein Business Dude.
Super Wolke-Clarity.
Alle immer Hipster-Apple-Zeug am Start?
Ja, ist klar.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das für eine tolle Technologie ist.
CD-Quality-Lossless-Audio.
Das hängt von der Quelle ab würde ich sagen.
Es hat sogar noch ein Mikrofon drin.
CD-Qualität, weil CD-Qualität tatsächlich nicht schlecht ist.
Hat mich jetzt nicht so angesprochen.
War das der Google Assistant Logo? Hab ich mir nicht so genau angeguckt.
Aber hat mich jetzt nicht so angesprochen ehrlich gesagt.
Dann hole ich mir lieber den Ananas-Stepper.
Gucken wir uns nicht an.
Der Kräutergarten.
Wer wollte sich noch nicht immer den Kräutergarten daheim instellen?
Spricht mich jetzt auch nicht so wahnsinnig an.
Aber es ist wirklich so.
Diese Kickstarter-Videos werden doch garantiert von dem gleichen Hersteller produziert, oder?
Es ist die gleiche Aufmachung, die gleiche Musik, gefühlt die gleichen Leute.
Sind nicht die gleichen Leute, aber die sehen alle sehr ähnlich aus.
Das sieht alles sehr gleich in der Aufmachung immer aus.
Wieder ein Laptop.
Oh hier, huge.
Erstmal CS-Knifen.
Hat er einen Skin.
Erstmal checken, ob die einen Handschuh-Skin hatten, Messerskin.
Ah na na na, das geht aber so nicht.
Das ist ziemlich nubig, oder?
So ein komisches fast Standardknife und keine ordentlichen Handschuhe.
Auch noch gegen Bots?
Nee, nee, nee.
Das ist die Map, wo sie letztens in diesem einen Turnier die Bombe in die Wand geklitscht haben.
Ein Student, ein Gamer, ein kreativer Profi oder ein Entrepreneur.
Was auch immer du tust, du hast einen Laptop.
Das Problem mit Laptops heute ist, dass sie wenige Porten haben, sind untergeräumt und nicht verwendbar.
Das ändert sich jetzt.
Untergeräumt und nicht verwendbar.
Wir wollen dir eine Desktops-Klasse-Experienz geben, mit voller Kustomisation von deinem Laptop.
Der Blackface Pro kann mir die gleichen Frames und die gleiche Leistung von meinem Laptop bekommen, wie ich mit meinem Computer zu Hause bin.
Das ändert meine Leben.
Oh ja, ganz bestimmt.
18k, mehr als ich.
Darf ich nichts sagen.
Bestimmt die Freundin vom Kunde oder so.
So schnell, nur mit einem Kabel.
Der CPU ist niedriger, die Effizienz ist besser und die Temperatur ist unter Kontrolle.
Mit einem einzigen Design gibt es eine Grafikkarte.
Du kannst eine Desktops-Performance mit Laptop-Kompromissen, eine Grafikkarte zuhause, faste Storage und alle essentiellen Porten anbieten, während du gleichzeitig deinen Laptop anbietest.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte und eine Hard Drive mit deinem Budget und Pref.
Der Blackface Pro gibt eine Plug-and-Play-Experienz und ist kompatibel mit Windows und Mac.
Du brauchst keine Profis, wenn du eine Grafikkarte mit dem Blackface Pro hast.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte mit dem Blackface Pro haben.
Um die All-in-One-Docking-Solution zu erreichen, ist der Blackface Pro mit einem Dual-Controller-System ausgestattet.
Es ist die ambitiöse Lösung, die zweimal die PCIe-E-Lanen verpackt, als die vorhandenen Grafikkart-Solutions.
Mit dieser tollen Performance kannst du eine grafikartige Grafikkarte mit dem Blackface Pro anbieten und Raw-Files wie Butter editieren.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte mit dem Blackface Pro anbieten und Raw-Files wie Butter editieren.
Wenn mein Mac Pro mit dem Blackface Pro zusammen ist, ist die Geschwindigkeit so schnell, dass du es dir nicht vorstellen kannst.
Es ist kompatibel mit Thunderbolt 3, dem kommenden USB 4.
Der Dual-Controller entschärft Thunderbolt und Thunderbolt 2. Mit 13 Porten befindet sich Blackface Pro mit einem 10 Gigabit Ethernet-Port und einer SD-Karte.
Es ist kompatibel und du kannst es dir mit dem Blackface Pro anbieten und Raw-Files wie Butter editieren.
Wenn mein Mac Pro zusammen ist, ist die Geschwindigkeit so schnell, dass du es dir nicht vorstellen kannst.
Unsere Leben sind von den Dingen definiert, die wir die wichtigsten halten. Die Menschen, die die Unterschiede machen.
Dann ist es nicht wert, die Frage zu stellen. Was wäre, wenn es ein Gerät, ein einfaches, schmales und effektives Alarm wäre, das sicherlich unsere Liebenden sicher und schützt?
Also, für die Menschen, die eine Unterschiede machen, müssen wir uns nicht fragen, was wir anders machen könnten.
Deshalb hat Alpha Home die Carego gegründet, die eine persönliche Alarm-Systeme, die sich um das Handy verbindet, um das Handy zu schützen.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich gerade mal zufällig meinen Volumen aufgebraucht habe?
Man muss es trotzdem übertragen und das braucht bestimmt nicht viel Bandbreite, aber Deutschland Netzabdeckung und so.
Man muss dafür sein Handy dabei haben.
Aber mein Handy hat doch schon GPS. Warum brauche ich noch mal ein extra GPS?
Wofür braucht man das denn?
Ich muss mein Handy dabei haben, dass ich quasi Updates senden kann. Aber wenn ich mein Handy dabei habe, habe ich doch schon die Möglichkeit, GPS zu empfangen und Updates zu senden.
Ja, du musst dein Smartphone. Alter, natürlich meine ich Smartphone.
Quatsch, Handy GPS ist top. Ja ok, zu Hause verstehe ich das. Wenn man das zu Hause umhängt, hat mein Opa auch so einen Alarm-Knopf.
Aber unterwegs, dann hast du ein Smartphone dabei.
Einmal im Jahr und dann funktioniert das NEVER. Im Leben nicht.
Wenn du das Ding wirklich verwendest zum tracken und Updates senden möchtest, das braucht Strom. Wenn du das wirklich permanent täglich verwendest, braucht das NEVER hält das ein Jahr.
Was wird denn da drin sein? Wenn es hochkommt mit 250 mAh Batterie oder sowas. Niemals ein Jahr, wenn man das regelmäßig verwendet.
Es ist so einfach als zu sagen, Hey Siri, find Cargo.
Es ist im Prinzip ein Notrufknopf.
Ja, warum nicht?
Wobei ich der Einsicht bin, es hängt von zu vielen Faktoren ab.
Die ganze Hausnotrufgeschichte ist so raufgelegt, dass sie verpflichtend funktionieren muss.
Ach so, was kostet der denn?
28 Euro.
Also mir wäre es zu unsicher. Also wenn mein Opa noch leben würde und wenn er wirklich sowas bräuchte, du brauchst ein Smartphone oder wahrscheinlich vielleicht auch WLAN, aber definitiv das NEVER. Niemals.
Du brauchst, der Internetanschluss muss funktionieren oder ein Smartphone da sein. Das ist von relativ vielen Faktoren abhängig, vor allem unterwegs, wo ich mich nicht so hundertprozentig darauf verlassen würde.
Was, nur iPhone only?
Achireve oder was auch immer. Klingt französisch, guck man sich nicht an.
Maskett, oh.
Das brauche ich.
Da kann Chico was zum Spielen. Da kann Chico mit der Roboterkatze spielen.
Die muss er wenigstens nicht anfauchen.
Also ich habe vorhin meine Katze spielen sehen, die sah etwas eleganter aus.
Na ja. Wie wäre es mit einer echten Katze?
Wie wäre es mit einer Katze?
Ich meine, wenn man eine Katze haben will, wie wäre es mit einer Katze?
Weil, da tut man wenigstens auch mal was Gutes.
Die kratzen nicht, wenn man aufpasst.
Die sieht aber nicht so glücklich aus.
Guckt mal, wie toll die Katze spielt.
Pi 4 ist da drin.
Open Source Katze.
Die ist überhaupt nicht autonom. Die hält nur drei Stunden.
Ja, das bringt ja auch nichts.
Wenn ich sowas holen würde, würde ich sowas holen, dass es daheim rumlaufen kann und mit meiner Katze ein bisschen interagiert.
Dass sie sich nicht langweilt.
Also dann doch lieber.
Dann doch lieber eine wirkliche, richtige Katze.
Weiß nicht.
Hi.
Moment, eine SSD-Karte für...
Eine SSD-Karte für iPhones.
Na ja, das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
Wall Sun hatten wir schon.
Den Trier auch, das auch.
Nano Book.
Stone Paper.
Aber warum, wieso, weshalb, warum ist es da?
Hm.
Warum, warum, warum brennt es eigentlich, wenn es feuerresistent ist?
Also wenn das, wenn das nicht brennt, warum brennt es?
Versteht ihr, was ich meine? Warum brennt es, wenn das nicht brennt?
Das war Benzin, hat da Benzin draufgeschm...
Ah ja, ein bisschen vom, vom, vom Feuerzeug, ja.
Äh, nee.
Moment, guckt euch mal an.
Das sieht irgendwie, irgendwie merkwürdig aus.
Ich weiß nicht, also, nee.
Bleib ich doch lieber mal meine echten Katze.
Bluetooth Audio Classes.
Immersive Audio Visual Protection.
Audio...
Im, im, ich versuche gerade diese zwei Wörter, diese zwei Wörter in Einklang zu bringen.
Immersive Audio Visual Protection.
Hast du Lautsprecher auf dem Ohr oder was soll das sein?
What the...
Das ist eine Konsole?
Im Leben, im Leben ist das kein ordentliches Audio, was da rauskommt.
Alternativ kann ich mir einfach in Ears anziehen und alles ist gut.
Nee, ich kann mir einfach in Ears anziehen.
Okay, wer es braucht?
Das Ding ist nach dreimal drücken kaputt, wenn ich mir den Knopf da angucke.
Das ist noch Fortnite.
Wie viel?
Vier Stunden, das ist ja nichts.
Vier Stunden, da kann ich nicht auf die Arbeit aufsetzen.
Das ist zur Mittagspause leer.
Das hat Schwachsinn.
Das ist super krass finanziert.
Also ich weiß nicht.
World's Smallest Phone.
Das juckt mich jetzt nicht so ehrlich gesagt.
So viele Zellen können...
1TB passt da angeblich rein.
Ah ja.
Wie schaffen die das mit den Zellen für den Flash, wenn das ordentliche Flashzellen sind?
Jo, warum nicht? Es hat schon seinen Grund, warum eine SSD, wenn die ordentliche Zellen hat, schon eine gewisse Größe hat.
Es gibt schon lange USB-Sticks, aber das ist ja angeblich eine richtige SSD.
Wenn Flashspeicher, ja es ist alles Flashspeicher, Flashspeicher ist das alles, aber eine SSD hat erstens Reservekapazität,
zweitens auch Zellen, die du öfters wieder beschreiben kannst und generell eine deutlich höhere Haltbarkeit als beispielsweise eine Micro SD-Karte oder ein USB-Stick.
Und außerdem ein bisschen schneller.
2TB.
2TB, also das ist im Endeffekt eine Micro SD-Karte als USB-Stick.
Oh ganz schön, ganz schön, ganz schön billig.
Also dem würde ich meine Daten nicht anvertrauen.
Es ist, ja aber naja, Micro SD-Karten in der Größe sind verdammt teuer.
So, guckt euch das mal an. 1TB Micro SD-Karte.
Und selbst eine Micro SD-Karte würde ich auf Dauer nicht allzu viel anvertrauen.
990 Dollar ist ganz schön, ganz schön billig.
Also dem würde ich keine Daten anvertrauen im Zeug.
Und booten würde ich davon schon mal gar nichts.
Das ist dann nach paar Mal gleich RIP.
USB-Sticks mit 2TB.
Das sind aber auch eher in Richtung richtigen Flash-Speicher.
China, 2TB, legit, legit 2TB.
Also das ist schon ganz schön nerver. Nie, nie im Leben, glaube ich nicht.
Die sehen halt in diesen Videos, die sehen alle immer so hipster Style aus.
Ne, Scammers, Scammers, glaube ich euch nicht.
20, Moment, 20, also 20.01.
Total, was ist TBW nochmal?
Terabytes Written, genau.
4000 Terabytes Written.
Das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen viel.
Was hat denn das da für einen Magic Controller drin und wie viel Reserve?
Das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht.
Das ist so ein typisches Produkt, das glaube ich erst, wenn es irgendeine vertrauenswürdige Seite getestet hat.
Was haben wir?
Da bin ich ja immer dafür für sowas.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das PHP-Logo.
Was ist das PHP-Logo, aber falschrum? Ist das jetzt im Trend?
Ja, stimmt, wenn es zu ist, heißt es richtig rum.
Genau so, so wird es in echt sein.
In der Vorschule sitzen sie im Labor und vor allem in Deutschland, na klar.
Das wäre cool, aber wenn wir nicht sind.
Da ist bestimmt eine RSP32 drin.
Das ist eine coole Idee.
Die Musik von diesen Kickstarter Videos ist immer gleich, immer sowas in dieser Richtung.
Ich finde die Idee nicht schlecht.
Wenn das gut funktioniert, vor allem wenn das so gemacht ist, dass man wirklich Kinder dazu animiert, da ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen, finde ich die Idee nicht schlecht.
Ja toll, sind schon da.
Ich finde es nicht schlecht, aber wenn das so gemacht ist, dass man wirklich Kinder dazu animiert, da ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen, finde ich die Idee nicht schlecht.
Ich finde die Idee nicht schlecht.
Das setzt aber eine Sache, warum das in Deutschland nicht funktioniert.
Wir haben keine Leute, die den Kindern das zeigen können.
Weil einfach den Kindern das hinschmeißen und Sachen machen mal, ist wahrscheinlich nicht so interessant.
Da müssen auch ein bisschen Leute dabei sein, die selbst Planen von haben und haben wir in Deutschland nicht.
Wen haben wir denn im Kindergarten oder in der Vorschule, der programmieren kann?
Gibt es doch nicht.
Was? Schau mal Link.
Ein Reddit Beitrag zu SST, ok.
Gucken wir uns gleich an.
Find ich nice, also gefällt mir.
Ok, es gibt einen Reddit Beitrag zur SST, die wir uns vorher angeguckt haben.
Ihr könnt doch einfach auf mich hören, das ist das erste was ich gesagt habe, vor allem für den Preis.
Also.
It cannot be done, ja.
Ja, passt halt nicht rein.
Scammers.
Scammed.
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
Big light for small spaces.
Das sieht cool aus, könnte ich für meinen Technikraum gebrauchen.
Ja, ihr macht es halt noch philosophischer, so nach dem Motto, ja wir bauen ein Licht.
Wir bauen ein Licht, und jetzt kommt dann Illumination, die Quelle allen Lebens, das Universum, was auch immer, zeigt halt einfach euer Ding.
Also, das Produkt, nicht euer Ding, ja.
Moment.
Moment, was?
Was juckt mich das?
Mir wurscht, wie das ist mit dem zusammenzuarbeiten, mich interessiert was da immer in der für ein Produkt rauskommt.
Erstmal ein schön Adoino, Adoino Lötkolben am Start.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Adoino Lötkolben gibt, da war zumindest Adoino Logo drauf.
Na ja gut, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen, die Helligkeit für ein Kleid, das mag vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben sein.
Also quasi die Sonne für den Serverraum.
Das kann ich aber auch mit dem ESP32 und der LED Lichterkette machen.
Ich meine, ich zeige euch mal was, wobei ich muss euch nicht zeigen, ich habe euch mal Weihnachtsbaum gezeigt.
Mein Weihnachtsbaum konnte das auch, und da war mit 15 Euro Hardware gebaut.
Ich meine, okay, der LED Strip von meinem Weihnachtsbaum, der ging bis hier, ja.
Da hätte ich ihn halt noch viermal verlängern müssen.
Aber für die Nubs ist das gut. Ja, wo kommt denn das Licht her?
Der stellt das da unten hin, und wo kommt das Licht her?
Das Licht wird ja da jetzt nicht rauskommen, wie soll das Licht von da unten oben auf den Schrank leuchten von oben?
Ah, kleine Sonne, Sonne für den Server-Schrank.
Weil wie will er da jetzt seine LED-Leiste hinmachen?
Da ist auch kein Platz.
Der redet schon so erhaben, oder? Erhaben trifft es da doch richtig.
Ja, unser neues Produkt, das ist so unglaublich, wie die Welt um dich herum herum.
Der redet schon voll abgehoben irgendwie, so erleuchtet redet er, erleuchtet.
Die Sekto um das fliegende Spaghetti Monster hat übrigens geklagt, dass sie als Religionsgemeinschaft anerkannt werden.
Ich glaube, es dauert dir eine Stunde, doch.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es geht überhaupt nicht um Beleuchtung, sondern um ein Gerät, wo man Beleuchtung mit steuern kann.
Ja, genau. Es geht nämlich überhaupt nicht um das eigentliche Licht.
Das kann ich im ESP 230 anmachen für 5 Euro.
Du kannst es nicht predikten, wie viele du hast. Die spawnen einfach bei dir im Schrank.
Stell dir mal vor, du stellst einen Luminuk unten in die Küche und auf einmal oben im Schrank steht auch noch einer.
Das ist einfach da. Und wird natürlich abgebucht.
Ach du Scheiße!
Meine Fresse! Jetzt tragen sie aber dick auf.
Jetzt haben sie aber dick aufgetragen.
Ich dachte, das ist eine schöne Lampe, die man von der Ecke klatscht und dann macht es immer schön hell.
Nein, das ist es nicht.
Oh, die Next Google hier.
Leider noch nicht finanziert.
Das ist ein Stock Image, oder?
Das ist ein Stock Image.
Das ist ein Stock Image. Der hat sich ein Stock Image gesucht mit Inside drauf und hat das Ding dann Inside genannt.
Besser als Google, besser als Google.
Und das ist, das ist doch niemals der Typ, niemals.
Das ist Stock-Foto. Der Dude da drauf auf dem Bild.
Das hat fast Schwachsinn.
Get your photos sent to... Warum?
Create your own brain to compute... Langsam wird es aber immer abgedreht, oder?
Environiment. Ah, es ist Französisch.
Keine Ahnung, wie man das so Französisch ausspricht.
Create your own computer.
Schauen wir mal, da oben doch schon.
AR, VR, MA can be magic.
Äh, what?
My Grill!
Endlich!
MA, ich hab keine Ahnung, ich hab jetzt Maschinen-Learning, aber das kann eigentlich nicht sein.
E-Brimo-Barbecue! Personalizable, was auch immer.
Okay, das ist ja richtiger Crap hier jetzt.
Die Leute, die Leute spenden gerne für, was heißt spenden? Fountain gerne?
Irgendwelche komischen Kopfhörer-Dinger.
Dot Power.
HiFi Stereo Sound Speaker for Echo Dot.
Mal so als Tipp, man könnte sich einfach ein paar ordentliche Lautsprecher hinstellen.
Und die hören sich dann auch, oh! Das, ohje, das Brauma.
Magic Toilet Pro.
Das Brauma.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Alles nicht so spannend.
Aquarium Automation. Gut, hab ich keine Verwendungswerte.
Magnetic Wireless Powerbank, Portable Battle.
Magnetic Powerbank?
Ist bestimmt super zu bedienen, wenn da hinten so eine Powerbank dran pappt.
Online Virtual Desktops.
Was, was möchtet ihr uns sagen?
Erstmal ein Video, was ich im Keller aufgenommen.
Oh ne, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch.
Das lese ich mir nicht durch.
Wir gucken uns lieber das Create Your Own Brain Computer Interface an.
Kennste Snips AI Max? Ja, kann man nicht mal verwenden.
Leider.
War ganz gut.
Peinliche Affe, ich hab nicht das Problem mit dem Video, sondern dass der irgendwie...
Das Video hätt ich mir sogar noch gegeben, aber...
Der Text, what the fuck?
Übertreib halt.
So, your computers, with your brain, we've made it easy for you. Check out these examples of what you could do at home with the Mind Effect Makers Kit.
Braincontroller VR-Games zu kontrollieren ist schon mit Händen und so nicht so ohne. Und jetzt soll ich das mit dem Hirn machen?
Vor allem, zieh mal sowas unter dein VR-Headset an.
Fuck.
Oh, er kann vorwärts und zurückfahren.
Und das nach 5 Sekunden Input-Lag.
Das ist ein ganz nice Proof of Concept, dass sowas geht.
Brauchen tut's. In diesem Stadium eigentlich kein Mensch.
What?
Das ist bestimmt voll anstrengend.
Also jetzt Leute, Magic Toilet Pro.
Der braucht noch viele Bäcker und es sind nur noch 4 Tage übrig.
Huge Video. Erstmal schöne Porn-Music ausgepackt.
Was ist das?
What?
Warum ist das Video hochkant?
Warum ist das Video hochkant und quer?
Moment, ich muss mich mal kurz auf die Seite legen. Vielleicht erkenne ich dann. Ja hier, da sind Kabel.
Magic Toilet.
Leute, wisst ihr was das ist?
Ich erkenne was das ist. Das ist ein Ultrasonic-Sensor.
Hier, das ist ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Seht ihr es?
Das sind 3 Ultraschall-Sensor nebeneinander.
Oder? Ja.
Das braucht man zum Abstand erkennen. Ich vermute mal, dass der das so macht, dass der hier mit Abstand erkennt und dann irgendwie hieran erkennen will in welche Richtung.
Deswegen musste die auch weglaufen. Wenn du aufstehst und bleibst davor stehen, dann spült er nicht.
Aber wenn der irgendwie mitbekommt, du entfernt dich, dann spült er. Irgendwie sowas. Dafür sind bestimmt die Ultraschall-Sensoren da.
Dass du es nach links mitkriegst, Mitte kriegst und irgendwie rechts. Irgendwie sowas.
Jede automatische Spülung funktioniert. Ja, aber nicht selbst gebaut mit einem 3D-getruckten Gehäuse, einem Arduino oder so drinnen und ein bisschen Zeug.
Wozu braucht man das jetzt, wenn das Vögel in deiner Toilette fliegen?
Pa! Pa! Die Musik ist ja geil, Alter!
Pass mal auf! Pa!
Okay, das Video war jetzt schon ziemlich schlecht. Alter, da muss man ja aufpassen hier. Muss man ja aufpassen, dass nicht gleich hier der Pedobeer anrückt.
Wer weiß, was man... Ich trau mich gar nicht weiter, das Video weiterzumachen.
Was leu... Ach du... Was leuchtet da eigentlich so? Guck mal, läuft... Ist da irgendwie eine Sirene im Hintergrund? Guckt euch mal die Wand an.
Warum flimmert die Wand so?
Kamera? Vielleicht. Also, ehrlich Leute, ganz, ganz ehrlich, sowas könnten wir auch selbst bauen, ohne Probleme.
Controller haben wir alle da. Sensoren haben wir auch da. Dann holen wir uns noch den Ananas-Stepper. Jetzt weiß ich auch, wozu wir den Ananas-Stepper brauchen.
Den Ananas-Stepper brauchen wir, um die Klospülung zu drücken. Oder wir holen uns den Finger-Bot, der drückt dann für uns die Klospülung.
Magic Toilet Plum. Ich glaube, das ist von jemand, der meint das... Der bastelt gern und der meint das halt auch wirklich ernst und ist davon überzeugt.
Er hat aber halt keine Marketing-Agentur, die das schön aufbereitet für ihn.
Das einzige Problem, was ich jetzt daran sehe, ist, du kannst halt keinem wirklich erzählen, sich so ein Ding aufs Klo zu stellen.
Niemand stellt sich so ein Ding aufs Klo.
Oder die Musik, wenn es halt in der Musik macht. Pow!
Hier gibt es noch ein bisschen bessere Auflösung.
Das sind Ultraschall-Sensoren. Das Ding sieht in einem Moment mal schön designt aus.
Sag doch mal hier! Ultrasonic-Sensor!
Wer hat's gesagt, Leute? Wer hat's gleich erkannt?
Huge.
Manchmal zahlt sich das doch aus, dass ich ein bisschen mit so Krams rumbastele ab und zu.
Predicted. Die Prediction.
Ich dachte, es kommen noch ein paar... Person detected.
Ready to fly.
Das sind drei Ultraschall-Sensoren. Da ist irgendein Controller drinnen und ein...
Das könnten wir ohne Probleme selbst machen.
WordArts.
Oh man, der Ananas-Dapper.
Social Scope.
Die Oma lernt VI? Ach nee.
Ich dachte, das ist ein Lernprogramm für meine Oma, dass sie VI bedienen kann danach.
Danach kommt Vim.
Smart-Prain-Training.
Okay, da ist jetzt schon ziemlich viel Shit auf einmal dabei.
Gehen wir nochmal hier auf die...
Auf die Gadgets. Auf die Gadgets-Entdecker.
Gucken wir mal, ob da noch was drin ist, was wir noch nicht hatten.
Hatten wir alles schon?
LED-Touch-Line...
Ohne Kabel?
Ja, dann halt mit Akku.
Okay, welche Features brauche ich bei einer kabellosen Lampe?
Ein An-Aus-Schalter.
Vielleicht Schnelligkeitsregler.
Also das ist sowas, was man easy sich basteln kann.
Was man aber nicht basteln will.
Und einen großen Akku, ja.
Gucken wir mal.
Kappa?
Ach, Kappa.
Ko-Kopa.
Nicht Kappa.
Golden Kappa-Check.
Kappa.
Falls ich jeden Tag mein Lampen umstelle.
Es ist ganz schön dunkel, oder?
Guck mal, guck mal auf den...
Der hat das gerade an- und ausgeschaltet und du siehst fast nichts.
Guck mal.
Seht ihr irgendwas auf dem Tisch?
Da ändert sich nichts vom Licht.
Guck mal auf dem Tisch.
Als wäre es nicht an.
Ah, das tut ja weh.
Da kann ich doch einfach ein Kabel dran machen.
WTF, 12 Stunden für eine Lampe.
Da machst du zwei Abende an oder einen Abend an und das Ding ist leer.
Also mathematisch gesehen habe ich mit sowas immer Probleme.
Wenn da steht 10 Minuten gleich 2 Stunden.
Das ist falsch.
Sie meinen damit, dass man in 10 Minuten 2 Stunden lädt.
Wahrscheinlich.
Kappa kann last for 2 hours.
Ich denke für 12.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
2 oder 12?
Hä?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Crap, oder?
Crap, hoffentlich.
Hoffentlich, gleich, gleich ausgemacht.
Weg eliminiert.
Hatten wir alle schon?
Okay, dann sind wir jetzt nochmal besonders.
Was?
Nano Rain, was?
Ah, für die Scheibe.
Ja, gucken wir uns mal an, was gerade besonders beliebt ist.
Hatten wir, hatten wir, hatten wir?
Hatten wir auch?
Die waren, die waren so abgedreht.
Das hatte schon was Sektenmäßiges.
Learn to Code 2020.
Na, das ist doch was für uns.
Da lernen wir endlich mal ordentlich programmieren.
Was hast du eigentlich für eine Maus?
Eine G403.
Mammut.
Das ist ja auch so easy.
Man lernt einfach mal nebenbei programmieren und schreibt dann in seine Perwerbung ein.
Erstmal der Mammut am Start.
Ja, aber wenn ihr so geile Kurse und Tutorials habt, damit verdient ihr ja sicherlich auch Geld.
Warum braucht ihr da einen Kickstarter?
Alles.
Da habt ihr alle Sachen, die miteinander relativ wenig zu tun haben, aber sportlich, sportlich, sportlich.
Ich muss halt dazu sagen, dass Python für Machine Learning ist so gut, für Game Development so gut wie nicht, kaum verbreitet.
Ich will nicht sagen, dass man in Python keine Games machen kann, aber welche Games fallen mir ein, die in Python sind?
Nicht viele.
Keine, um ehrlich zu sein.
Und Apps machst du auch nicht in Python normalerweise und Webseiten auch nicht.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, man kann sich einfach einen Udemy Kurs oder sowas holen.
Der kostet dann 15, 15, 15 Euro, hat 35 Videos und man kann danach Python halbwegs, wenn man auch mitmacht.
Ok, jetzt ist es wirklich Python.
Aber ich will Python.
Schwachsinn.
Blödsinn, brauchen wir nicht.
Da bin ich immer interessiert dran, was es da so gibt.
Was ist denn das für eine Münze?
Irgendein Penny oder so?
UK Währung.
Peter von Microsoft.
Das ist wirklich klein.
Das ist cool.
Man kann sogar noch Pins anlöten.
Das ist Absicht, dass die nur so halb sind, gibt es ein paar Sachen.
Das ist echt ziemlich klein.
Es gibt kleinere Arduino.
Mir fällt zumindest jetzt keiner ein.
Ja doch, es gibt die AT-Tiny-Dinger und sowas.
Aber es kommt drauf an, was drin ist.
Das ist ein ganz normaler Atmel 015 Arduino-Ding.
Aber das ist doch unbestanden.
Moment, ich denke, es geht um ein Arduino-Board.
Ich kann damit alles Mögliche machen, was ich machen kann.
Das kann ich auch mit jedem anderen Controller, da brauche ich ihn nicht so klein.
Ja, die Specs interessieren mich auch.
Ja klar.
Wie viel Flash, wie viel RAM.
Das ist ein ganz normaler DHT11.
Das ist ein ganz normales SSD1306.
Also im Prinzip sind das ganz normal nur noch 15 Zeug.
Acceleration Sensor glaube ich.
Das ist ein normales Arduino.
Die sind auch schon viel kleiner geworden.
Davon habe ich mir mal ein paar bestellt, die sind abartig zu programmieren.
Da musst du voll durch zig Hürden springen.
Zeig mal, was dein Board kann.
Es ist ja schon wirklich klein, das ist gut.
WLAN?
Kein WLAN, oder?
Wenn es WLAN hätte, würde man die Antenne hier drauf sehen irgendwo.
Kein WLAN ist schon mal ziemlich doof, muss man sagen.
Weil WLAN ist so omnipräsent heute.
Es gibt Anwendungszwecke ohne WLAN.
Man kann natürlich da vielleicht noch irgendwie einen RF-Controller dran machen.
Deswegen sind die ESPs auch so toll.
Die gibt es auch an ziemlich klein und haben halt immer WLAN.
Er hat halbwegs viele Pins, das ist schon mal in Ordnung.
Voila!
Ja, gut.
Ja, es ist ein kleiner Arduino.
Die Frage ist jetzt nur, Traumverbrauch?
Stromverbrauch wäre sehr interessant.
WLAN gibt es keins.
Das ist schon mal doof.
Aber Deep Sleep Stromverbrauch, das ist eigentlich das wichtigste bei so einem Ding.
Wird da irgendwie was?
Ja, er ist ziemlich langsam.
Er hat auch nicht gerade viel Flash.
Man darf nicht vergessen, so eine ESP 2866, wenn ich da eine Firmware kompiliere, ist die teilweise schon 2,5 MB oder so.
Oder waren es 1,5.
Hängt der Verbrauch nicht einfach vom Micro-Controller ab, nicht nur.
Das Ding hat zum Beispiel einen USB dran.
Wahrscheinlich zieht der Spannungswander für den USB mehr.
Pass auf, dass du nicht auf den Suchverlauf gehst.
Welchen Suchverlauf?
10 Watt, willst du mich verarschen?
10 Watt, 10 Watt ist der Witz.
Das Ding braucht paar Milliampere.
Das sind 3,3 Volt, paar Milliampere.
Aber die Dinger brauchen nichts.
Der Spannungswander USB ist die Frage, ob der ausgeschaltet mit dem Deep Sleep und so was.
So ein Board sind 5 Volt, übrigens.
Ja, 0,3. Die Dinger brauchen nichts.
Aber nichts ist immer noch zu viel auf Batterie und Deep Sleep.
Alles ist zu viel.
Wir reden bei Deep Sleep geeigneten Boards nicht von Milliampere, sondern von Microampere.
Dass es halbwegs lange an der Batterie läuft.
Das Ding darf im Deep Sleep 1020 Microampere brauchen.
Wenn ich das jetzt Mist erzähle.
Dann hält es ein Jahr an der Batterie.
Aber leider fehlt da nichts zu Power Consumption.
Hat das überhaupt eine gescheite Möglichkeit?
Man kann das doch nicht mal ordentlich per Batterie betreiben, sehe ich gerade.
Man kann das doch nicht mal ordentlich per Batterie betreiben, weil das ist ein 5 Volt Board.
Die normalen Akkus haben vollgeladen 4,2 Volt und gehen dann immer weiter runter.
Deswegen brauchst du eigentlich Boards, die mit 3,3 Laufen.
Und halt auch ein bisschen mehr aushalten.
Hat das keine 5 Volt und Crownpinsel?
Doch, aber dein Akku nicht.
Die normalen Akkus haben vollgeladen 4,2 Volt.
Und die droppen dann runter, je nach Mitentladungsstand.
Damit kannst du das Ding schon mal gar nicht betreiben.
Zumal es wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht geht, dass ich einen Pin als Input verwende.
Da waren es 3,7, ich glaube 4,2 vollgeladen.
Hat mich jetzt nicht so überzeugt.
Sah interessant aus, das Projekt, aber ich habe jetzt wenig Anwendungszwecke für...
Dann bin ich jetzt schon an. 3,5 Stunden WTF.
Das ist gut für mich.
Das wäre gut für mich.
Da kann ich ordentliche Aufnahmen machen.
3,7, ja dann ist es 3,7, aber voll 3,7.
Gut, Scheinwerfer.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Ob das was taugt?
Ist das alles USB?
Warum nicht?
Ja Leute, war doch ganz interessant.
Also mir reicht es jetzt.
Ich muss in einer halben Stunde durchpennen gehen, morgen wieder aufstehen.
Gibt es irgendwas was ihr wissen wollt?
Ah ja, ja.
Guck mal ob es irgendwelche Leute gibt, die ich hausgehen kann.
Okay Leute, wir sehen uns dann die Tage.
Alles gut.
Wir sehen uns, bis dann.